[Musique]
Laurent Richard bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succint
ouais je m'appelle donc Laurent Richard
je suis journaliste je vais avoir 40 38
ans dans dans 2 mois ça fait un peu plus
de 25 ans que je fais ça ce métier là
que j'aime beaucoup
euh
et et j'ai fait beaucoup essentiellement
ce qu'on appelle des investigations qui
consiste à faire parler des gens qui
veulent pas trop de parler au départ euh
sur des sujets je me suis jamais
vraiment spécialisé sur quoi que ce soit
j'ai fait des sujets sur l'industrie
bancaire sur l'industrie financière j'ai
fait des sujets en Irak plusieurs fois
j'ai l'un de mes premiers sujets un peu
long c'était sur la guerre du cachemir
entre l'Inde et le Pakistan et le sort
des Cachmir au milieu donc j'ai pas une
spécialité j'ai jamais voulu me
spécialiser aussi pour pour pas dépendre
d'un seul service en particulier pour
pouvoir être assez libre euh et on a
besoin de ça pour pour pouvoir enquêter
et et puis au fil du temps j'ai
participer activement à des émissions
d'investigation donc j'ai travaillé au
départ pour pièce à conviction pendant 4
ans c'est là où j'ai rencontré lise Lucé
qui était une et Hervé Brusini euh qui
était qui était le fondateur de de pièce
à conviction euh c'est une expérience
que j'ai vachement aimé qui m'a amené à
enquêter un peu partout et puis et puis
après le passage à pièce à conviction
qui était donc sur le service public
j'ai travaillé à l'agence ka où j'étais
rédacteur en chef et je faisais toujours
de l'investigation et après lise Luc m'a
proposé de de cofonder avec elle et
Jean-Pierre Canet le magazine cashe
investigation j'ai passé pas mal de
temps sur ça sur le développement de de
cach puis après j'en ai eu marre un peu
de la rédaction en chef j'ai voulu
repartir sur le terrain et puis après il
s'est passé plein de trucs et entre
autres l'envie de créer un réseau
mondial qui s'appelle forbidden stories
que je dirige aujourd'hui on a bientôt 7
ans et forbidden stories c'est une
organisation donc mondiale de
journalistes d'investigation
journalistes avec une mission qui est
assez unique on poursuit les enquêtes
des reporters assassinés emprisonnés ou
menacés
et donc on le fait depuis Paris mais on
notre réseau est international on
90 organisations de presse qui
travaillent avec nous 200 journalistes à
peu près depuis le départ c'est quoi vos
trophées euh je sais pas si on peut
parler de trophée en matière de
journalisme mais on a je sais pas on a
révélé le projet on a fait le projet
Pegasus donc on a révélé beaucoup
d'informations sur ce logiciel espion
qui s'appelle Pegasus
vendu à de nombreux États utilisés par
de nombreux États contre de nombreux
citoyens partout dans le monde qui ont
une petite particularité en commun c'est
qu' en général ils sont journalistes
dissidents avocats militant des droits
de l'homme ils essayent de travailler
pour unre qui s'appelle la démocratie et
se retrouver il se retrouve ciblé par
cette arme qui est une arme militaire
utilisée contre des civils je pense
qu'on on en reparlera tout à l'heure
mais c'est c'est un sujet hyper
intéressant et et grave pour nous pour
notre démocratie ça fait partie des
menaces les menaces globalement contre
les journalistes ou le journalisme ou
plus largement l'accès à l'information
elles ont totalement changé de forme en
vraiment 5 10 ans sur la désinformation
sur la Cyb sururveillance et et donc
avec forbidden stories on a aussi
pouruivi par exemple le travail d'une
journaliste qui s'appelait Gury lquche
qui était une journaliste indienne qui
travaillait sur les réseaux de la
désinformation et qui voulait savoir qui
se cachait derrière certaines armées de
troll qui se cachait quelle était la
connexion entre ce parti po
nationaliste et cette entreprise qui se
retrouvait à la harceler en ligne ou à
pratiquer lui refaire sa réputation avec
avec en en diffusant sur internet de de
fausses infos elle a enquêté là-dessus
et ça lui en a coûté la vie elle a été
assassinée de deux balles dans la tête
et on a poursuivi le travail de Gabriel
enquche et en poursuivant son travail on
a enquêter sur l'industrie de la
désinformation et ça nous a amené entre
autres à s'intéresser à des anciens de
cambrid antica qui était une entreprise
qui était euh qui s'est fait connaître
pour avoir manipulé sur le temps des
élections américaines mais aussi sur le
temps de l'élection au brexit en
Angleterre manipuler les masses
globalement on peut y revenir plus tard
mais on pour nous chez forbidon voilà on
poursuit les enquêtes de reporters qui
sont qui ont pas pu aboutir et on le
fait pas dans un réflexe seulement
confraternel le but c'est pas de rendre
hommage aux journalistes le but c'est de
considérer que en fait la première
victime c'est évidemment le journaliste
mais la deuxième c'est nous tous c'est
le citoyen c'est celui qui n'a pas
l'info et le journaliste il est tué il
est assassiné il est censuré pas parce
qu'il est journaliste pas parce qu'il
est Michel ou Fred parce qu'il porte une
information et qui s'apprête à la
publier ou parce qu'il vient de la
publier et cette information elle est
gênante elle est gênante parce qu'elle
va déranger un pouvoir en place elle est
gênante parce qu'elle va révéler les
liens d'un oligarque avec une entreprise
avec elle va enquêter sur va publier
d'informations sur l'évasion fiscale et
il va être assassiné pour ça il ou elle
va être assassiné pour ça et donc le but
de cette démarche de forbidden stories
en fait mon idée de départ c'était de de
se dire bah à plusieurs on est plus fort
c'est tout simple c'était aussi le
sloganhilary Clinton stronger together
truc comme ça mais c'était un peu bête
de quoi elle nous l'a piqué elle vous
l'a piqué à vous ouais je pense ça a
bien circulé mais c'est l'idée toute
simple de de si on travaille ensemble en
fait on peut et qu'on reprend l'enquête
d'un journaliste qui a é assassiné et
qu'on la publie partout dans le monde à
la même heure à la même seconde parce
qu'elle portait sur un crime
environnemental parce qu'elle portait
sur la pollution de cette entreprise de
T rivière dans le nord de la Colombie
celui qui a voulu tuer le journaliste va
se rendre compte qu'en fait c'est
contre-productif que l'acheter il vaut
bah il vaut mieux le laisser faire parce
que parce que ça s'appelle l'accès à
l'information et que sans information il
y a pas de démocratie et que et donc
notre but notre démarche c'est pas donc
une démarche JUSE qu' fraternel c'est
une démarche au nom de l'accès à l'info
de se dire ils ont tué le messager ils
tueront jamais le message et c'est de
faire en sorte que les gens aient accès
à à cette information là quand un
journaliste tombe on est 50
à à poursuivre son travail à se dire
pourquoi il a été assassiné sur quoi il
travaillait et on va poursuivre son
travail on va le publier on va aller
plus loin que son enquête on va essayer
de retrouver ses sources on va et on va
le publier pas seulement à Malte là où
dfneé a été assassiné pas seulement à
Baku en Azerbaidjan mais partout dans le
monde et et ma conviction c'est que oui
a plusieurs on est plus fort parce qu'on
est inarrêtable ça sert à rien de d'en
tuer un on est il y en a 42
fautres je commence première question
pourquoi les gens détestent la plus
grande partie les journalistes pourquoi
il y a une défiance envers la presse en
ce moment et d'ailleurs c'est mondial
ouais pourquoi c'est une question super
importante c'est qu'il faut toujours se
poser
euh c'est très moi quand j'ai voulu
devenir journaliste il y a 25 ans
c'était assez populaire quasiment d'êt
journaliste autour de moi on me disait
c'est cool c'est un métier où tu voyages
tu es témoins de l'histoire c'est super
d'être journaliste c'était assez
encouragé même par la société je
trouvais il y a y a 25 ans entre
tempemps il s'est passé pas mal de trucs
aujourd'hui on est aussi populaire qu'un
chauffeur de taxi non non croquement ou
croque mort je sais pas euh ça dépend
des sondages les sondages disent pas
tous la même chose non plus les
chauffeurs taxi sont très populaires pas
ceux de Paris je crois
mais
mais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il y a une
défiance à l'endroit des journalistes et
euh et qui ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il y
a un vrai truc à régler alors le sujet
il est complexe la question c'est
pourquoi pourquoi ben parce que les
journalistes parfois on parfois les
journalistes en fait on en fait il y a
il y a à la fois un système qui a un
système des chaînes enfantue des réseaux
sociaux qui ont considéré et puis les
algorithmes qui se sont nourris de ça et
qui ont considéré Queen fait des
opinions très tranchées se partager plus
qu'une information nuancée et ça c'est
je pense l'une des clés du truc c'est
que les chaînes info incontinu quand
elles ont été créées donc il y a quand
même 20 ans de ça au moins bah on a
commencé à inviter un expert je sais pas
sur l'Ukraine à 15h15 mais on lui
demandait de rester en plateau à 15h45
pour parler je sais pas de la taxe sur
la carte grise par exemple quoi et on a
fabriqué des notre système euh mais je
dis notre parce enfin pas seulement le
système français en fait ça se réplique
à l'échelle mondiale euh et c'est pas
seulement la faute du système le système
nourrit en face un une une demande où on
se retrouve nous face à regarder et ou à
écouter une radio pendant 10h qui est en
Bou sur la même info et on se fait notre
cerveau se fait vite neutraliser en fait
par cette ce flot d'information continue
et d'expertise et donc le pourquoi la
question que tu posais c'était pourquoi
finalement il y a une défiance moi je
pense que il y a une défiance parce que
les gens se disent ok la personne qui
parle et qui a une écharpe rouge autour
du de son coup ou pas et qui me donne
une est-ce que c'est une information qui
me donne ou est que c'est son opinion et
là c'est la pour moi c'est la première
étape de la de la route vers la défiance
et de là où on a perdu un peu les gens
c'estd que finalement on se dit mais
est-ce que il me donne son opinion et à
limite pourquoi pas mais à ce moment-là
il faut plus marquer journaliste dans le
synthè c'estd en fait en bas de l'écran
il faut marquer voilà opinion writer il
faut enfin éditorialisteoriste mais il
faut le dire franchement euh mais c'est
le même sujet quand on invite un je sais
pas ouais un ouais un journal
journaliste a donné une opinion sur
quelque chose sur laquel il a pas il a
pas travaillé pour moi le journalisme
c'est c'est un travail c'est pas juste
bah je pense que c'est la guerre en
Ukraine c'est ça non non c'est c'est un
process en fait c'est un truc d'artisan
c'est un ébénist qui travaille son bois
jusqu'à ce que la pièce elle soit bonne
et puis parfois elle est pas bonne il
faut la reprendre il faut retravailler
l'obtention d'une avant de donner l'info
il faut l'obtenir pour l'obtenir il y a
un process il y a des chartes qui
régissent ça il y a des les lois vont
différer de pays en pays les usages
aussi tous les moi je travaille a des
journalistes dans le monde entier tout
le monde n' pas forcément les mêmes
moyens il y a plein de journalistes en
Amérique latine qui font un travail
remarquable de journalist de
journalistes mais qui ne peuvent pas qui
ne font pas que journalistes ils sont
aussi vous gagnez qui forbiden stories
moi moi je gagne 5600 € net donc j'ai un
bon salaire de directeur de publication
qui est largement audessus de la moyenne
des journalistes français et largement
a-dessus de la moyenne des journalistes
en Amérique latine -moi la première
question ouais
la défiance ouais j'ai j'ai trouvé que
l'argumentaire était enrobé de papier de
soi je n'ai pas entendu le les ménages
ouais parce que a pas encore temps pas
je n'ai pas entendu je travaille pour un
tel ou je suis digiganté pour un tel ou
je suis sous le robinet de ou je
présente les fait de telle façon bien
sûr non non mais ça c'est c'était parce
que juste c'était pour démarrer c'est et
je pense que cette histoire de juste
pardon de de de de confusion entre
l'opinion et l'info qui me parle en fait
est-ce que est-ce que la personne qui me
parle elle a travaillé sur le terrain
est-ce qu'elle est allée à Gaza est-ce
qu'elle est allée enquêter est-ce
qu'elle est est-ce qu'elle est allée
enquêter sur la cyburveillance avant de
me parler de cybersurveillance voilà
quelle est le process en fait d'où d'où
on me parle et c'est ça le journalisme
et c'est la beauté de ce métier là aussi
c'est que on est payé pour aller écouter
les gens les contredire relever la
contradiction et puis raconter ça avec
un Maxim d'honnêteté par rapport au
témoignages que l'on a pu avoir et puis
faire et puis aller sur des sujets qui
qui fâchent le reste c'est de la
communication c'est quoi les sujets qui
fâchent bah sujets qui F c'est les
sujets qui veulent pas être abordés par
une entreprise je sais pas moi j'ai
vachement enquêté sur l'entreprise
Philippe Maurice donc qui vend qui est
un des leaders dans le Monde du tabac
j'avais enquêté parce que j'avais trouvé
une
étude faite par Philippe Maurice qui
était ça c'était un sujet qui fâchait
vraiment où en gros pour convaincre ils
avaient trouveré le le truc pour
convaincre un état de moins taxer la
vente de cigarettes donc pour pouvoir il
disait entreut l'état de chèque si vous
voulez moins taxer si vous voulez que
moins taxer le tabac il faut que vous
vous rendez compte d'un truc c'est que
en fait les fumeurs on a calculé en
général meurt et quand il meurt d'une
maladie CR ils meurent exactement à
l'âge où normalement il touchent les
pensions que vous devriez leur reverser
en terme de retraite ça c'est pas sorti
d'une tête d'un conspirationniste
c'était une étude diligentée par
Philippe mauriis international et donc
j'ai récupéré cette étude et puis on est
allé interroger Philippe ça c'est un
sujet qui fasse donc ça c'est sujet où
il faut que la boîte veut pas aborder
donc après il faut être malin pour aller
faire parler la boîte là-dessus et lui
poser des questions je vais passer du
cocalan pour essayer de déconcentrer les
choses j'ai pas répondu à totalement la
question au papier de so tout çaou on va
y revenir comment vous trouvez que la
couverture sur le covid a été réalisé
c'était de qualité pas de qualité
c'était pour aller dans un sens quand on
entend la directrice je crois BFM qui
dit oui mais on a préféré aller dans ce
sens là parce que le gouvernement il a
dit c'est dans ce sens là il fallait pas
le contrarier sincèrement je sincèrement
je sais pas trop trivialement je je
demande à me faire fa checker non parce
que le au moment du sincèrement et
peut-être que je répéterai ça plusieurs
fois pour l'interview au moment du covid
je travaille sur Pegasus et j'étais dans
un nautisme absolu pendant un an et demi
euh là-dessus donc la couverture
médiatique du covid je me souviens de
énorme tâonnement du gouvernement
d'abord sur les les mesures et et puis
les médias qui sont retrouvés à suivre
les experts plus ou moins officiel nommé
pour donner des conseils là-dessus quoi
mais sincèrement j'ai pas de j'ai pas
fait d'enquête dessus donc je seraai pas
qualifié là de faire unee enquête quand
on dit au pharmaciens les masques ça
sert à rien si vous en vendez c'est 1 €
l'amende faut pas sortir de saincir pour
voir que le gouvernement était en short
n'avait pas de stock ouais ouais et
pourquoi les journalistes n'ont pas
essayé de dire VO là compliqué quand
même non je sais pas sincèrement
là-dessus sur le covid sincèrement je
sais pas je peux répondre à d'autres
questions sur où où les
journalistes on n pas fait notre boulot
ou ou d'autres n'ont pas fait leur
boulot je ou une façon de faire
journalisme moi je je pardon vas-y vas-y
je t'en prie on est bien on est bien
éduqué ici ouais ok et quand on pour
revenir sur la défiance et rebondir sur
la
défiance il y a encore des journalistes
qui font leur boulot en général quand on
en passe un c'est que on peut pas le
détruire il fait correctement son
travail ou qui qui a été envoyé par un
autre journaliste un vieux un viux on
lui passe le
bonjour mais les les les les gens
normaux
pense que votre cast professionnel éminé
par des gens qui sont tenus en l'ISS par
le salaire il mangeent des clopinettes
payé au lance-pierre à la pige et donc
c'est facile de les mettre aux ordres et
que on voit pas beaucoup de têtes brûlé
dans les journaliste on voit pas
beaucoup de de tête brûlée avec la tête
burinée l'ulcère de l'estomac la
pathologie alcoolique qui va avec
l'ultra tabagisme bon toi tu es au
triathlon c'est à peu près la même chose
on voit surtout des gens pomponnés
buvant des coups dans le 12e dans le 11e
ah c'est pas vrai et non mais je fais je
me fais la du diable ouais je on les
voit être dans les mêmes réseaux dans
les mêmes soiré dans les mêmes
vernissages et comme ça mais on voit des
journalistes payés 1600 balles
travailler comme des moines bénédicttin
des jeunes menacés et arrêtz ouais arrêz
parce qu'ils sont dégoûtés de cet effet
de on est journaliste on est au-dessus
euh ce petit ton prétentieux
ou militant politique il y a est-ce que
est-ce que les journalistes ne sont pas
trop militants politiques donnent leur
opinion essayent de faire fermer la
bouche parfois si de du camp qu'il ne
supporte pas pourquoi ils ne font pas
leur travail d'indépendance non mais al
attends moi je vais dire un truc déjà je
dirais pas ils ne font pas leur travail
d'indépendance parce que le il je sais
pas qui c'est euh ça répse hein ouais
mais franchement
et moi je suis prêt à passer mes 8hures
d'affile là-dessus pour apporter la
nuance la complexité et sans aucune
langue de bois il y a des trucs récents
qui m'ont mais totalement choqué
l'histoire je sais pas si tu as suivi de
BFM TV dans la la fausse interview de
ZAD takedin ou il y avait un autre
présentateur aussi qui é qui faisait des
ménages pour le baroc je crois non oui
oui oui qu'on a révél mais le Z kakedine
qui se rétracte avec marchandouais voilà
et il y a peu de temps de ça je crois
que c'était au début de l'été il y a eu
des révélations qui ont montré des
conversations entre Marc Olivier Fogel
qui était le directeur général de BFM TV
Fabri
SFI qui a sorti l'info ouais c'est Fabri
SFI qui sorti l'info mais Marco fog le
directeur de BFM TV discuter
avec je crois Véronique Vachet qui était
l'attaché de presse de Nicolas Sarkozi
et en sourcé ça ah oui c'est c'est très
c'est plus que sourcé c'est écouter
puisque c'était des écoutes jeici et en
fait c'est comme ça que ça a été révélé
c'est parce que Véronique Vachet je
pense était sous faisait l'objet d'une
écoute et que ça a été ça l'écoute à
fuité les conversations sont je vous
invite à lire les articles de méiaap
part sont incroyables en fait de la
c'est pas seulement de la connivance là
on est dans un dans un langage
où l'ancien chef de l'État par la voix
de son attaché de presse fait contacter
le directeur général d'une chaîne mais
aussi des chroniqueurs pour dire on a le
module le clip de Ziad takedin où on lui
a mis un microcravate comme ça pour lui
dire c'est pas vrai machin j'ai jamais
donner d'argent euh est-ce que vous
pouvez le diffuser et la réponse en face
c'est on va le diffuser mais on va le
bastonner et le mot bastonner d'ailleurs
m'a choqué m'a marqué
euh on va le bastonner c'est on va le
diffuser en boucle et euh et tout le
tout le langage raconte raconte ce un
truc euh qui fait qui fait peur
ce un niveau de connivance là en
l'espèce une
proximité je dis pas que les politiques
ne peent pas parler au journalistes ils
doivent se parler évidemment ensemble
mais par contre les journalistes ne sont
pas là pour diffuser à la commande à la
demande quelque chose qui serait qui
pour le coup était totalement trafiqué
monté c'était des faux aveux et qui ne
servaiit qu'à une chose c'était une
grande programmation pour blanchir
l'ancien président Nicolas Sarkozi dans
une affaire grave euh
donc ça ça participe énormément de la
défiance du citoyen en du journaliste
quand il part qui se dit ok comment je
fais maintenant pour croire BFM TV mais
ça a choqué à l'intérieur de BFM TV la
SDJ de BFM TV c'est mobilisé à vootter
une motion de défiance et tout ça il y a
donc c'est pour ça que dans le h faut
faire gaffe parce que le il tous les
gens à BFM TV sont pas comme ça et que
et que il y a un un deuxième truc
important c'est qu'il faut se battre en
fait tout le temps surtout c'est c'est
le le plus gros
danger j'ai participé avec Fabrice
harfille à et Paul morira on a un livre
qui s'appelle informé n'est pas enell on
avait cocréé informé n'est pas enell à
un moment donné c'était en 2015 où une
personne qui s'appelait Emmanuel Macron
qui était ministre de l'économie et des
finances projetéit de d'introduire via
la loi ce qu'on appelle la loi Macron le
secret un amendement sur le secret des
affaires et ça c'est c'était ce qu'on
appelle un petit cavalier c'était un
truc à l'intérieur d'une loi qui était
censé être indolor inodor et G qui va
bien entre g et et on a appris ça que en
fait l'objet de l'amendement c'était de
dire un journaliste qui est en
possession d'un document genre de
Philipp moi de Philippe Maurice l'étude
sur la la la rentabilité des morts du
tabac un journaliste qui détient qui
tient dans sa main un document qui vient
d'une entreprise et qui serait couvert
par le secret des affaires et et le
secret des affaires seul les entreprises
le définissent c'est qu'en gros tout
document qui a à voir avec ton business
ton entreprise la la couleur de ta
future voiture que tu produis je tout
toute information relative à ton à ton
business plan peut être couvert par le
secret des affaires mais si un
journaliste le projet c'est de dire un
journaliste qui révèle le secret des
affaires peut être pass possible de
peine de prison il peut aller en prison
donc c'était CIT une façon de tuer le
journalisme donc on s'est mobilisé et
avec Fabrice harfy avec Édouard Perin
avec Virginie Marquet avec Benoît
Colomba de la cellule investigation de
Radio France on est allé voir Emmanuel
Macron qui nous a euh reçu je pense CIT
fin janvier 2015 et qui était donc
ministre de l'Économie et il nous a reçu
à je raconte ça juste pour expliquer
qu'il faut se battre en fait tout le
temps parce que même si on est en France
et qu'on est censé être une démocratie
en en pleine vitalité il faut se battre
surtout parce que tout quoi dire sensé
B parce que on du point de vue de
l'extérieur on est le pays des droits de
l'homme de liberté fondamental ça fait
combien de temps que tu as pas voyagé
mon ami si justement je je ben quand je
voyage j'explique où on en est aussi
j'explique que on a des journalistes qui
sont en gardé à vue dans les sous-sols
de la des GSI non non au contraire
j'explique ça euh ilent les ganants bah
ils comprennent pas et tout après je
leur explique aussi que on a un service
public qui diffuse 40 nouveaux
documentaires par semaine et j'ai vécu
aux États-Unis quand je leur expliqué ça
he revenons à Macron je reviens à Macron
mais après je défendrai aussi un peu le
journalisme aussi c'est important parce
que c'est moi je te propose un truc ou
moi je te défonce tu les défends on fait
comme ça je fais l'avocat du diable on a
pas besoin je pense pas qu'on ait besoin
de
ça non mais tu peux tu peux faire non
mais ce que je voulais juste dire en
tout cas sur Macron pour revenir à ça
c'est qu'il nous a reçu et on est on est
arrivé dans dans ce bureau à Bercy il
nous attendait il était assis il y avait
4 cinq conseillers euh je pense que
j'étais le plus âgé et j'avais face de
l'ascenseur pour aller sur les liport
ouais non pas loin du Petit Bateau en
tout cas qui traverse la scène euh et il
nous a reçu il n a dit mais ah oui
l'amendement vous dérange mais venez
venez assez-vous comment vous voulez
qu'on qu'on le fasse euh et euh on était
plusieurs je raappelle Fabrice lu a dit
mais euh non on va pas faire un
amendement sur un coin de table dans
l'opacité totale là comme ça ensemble
on est juste là pour rappeler que en
fait le secret des affaires auquelles
vous pensez et qui allait passer si on
ne l'avait pas si on nous avait pas
alerté là-dessus allit finalement tuer
l'information et des scandales comme le
Médiator et des scandales comme plein
d'autres plein d'autres sujets en fait
n'auraient jamais été porté la
connaissance du citoyen et sans
information il y a pas de démocratie
donc ce que vous alliez faire c'est
grave donc là il nous a dit oui mais ça
vient pas de moi ça vient de matin
je vais voir ce que je peux faire est-ce
que voilà et donc on a on était venu
pour dire que c'était en l' état
impossible pour la profession de laisser
passer quelque chose et qu'on se
battrait là-dessus et puis finalement
l'amendement a été retiré on était
soulagé mais de semaines après on a
appris qu'une directive européenne
allait réinjecter le secret des affaires
euh à l'échelle d'une directive
européenne donc bien plus grande et là
on s'est rebattu aussi euh avec ce même
collectif pour faire en sorte que ce
soit amendé et que les journalistes les
lanceurs d'alerte puissent aussi voilà
bénéficier
d'exception alors se battre c'est se
mettre en groupe aller voir les
politiques leur attirer l'attention que
ça vous met un petit peu l'information
vous votre profession dans la mouise h
bon quand vous avez une mafia
politico-financière ou des gars qui
veulent faire taire une un journaliste
ou qui lui met une balle dans la tête ou
elle termine dans un coffre ou elle
termine démembrer si est dans une une
ambassade avec un mec qui met un petit
casque avec un de la
musique se battre certes c'est faire des
enquêtes révéler tout ça mais vous avez
pas eu envie et de vous fâcher un peu
c'est-à-dire aller aller leur expliquer
avec leur méthode que maintenant ça
suffit non moi le la seule méthode que
je connais c'est le journalisme le seul
truc que je sais faire dans la vie c'est
du journalisme je sais pas faire de la
menace de l'insulte de l'jure les gens
qui menacent et qui insultent c'est les
gens qui qui ne font rien par contre
faut se méfier des gens silencieux non
par contre non mais moi je peux
expliquer je peux peut-être raconter un
peu le contexte et à quoi ça ressemble
une journée chez forbidon stories
euh le Pr la première enquête qu'on a
mené ça commence en 2017
et un jour d'octobre 2017 daphneé Carona
Galizia une journaliste qui est maltaise
donc un pays membre de l'Union
européenne c'est un petit pays 400000
habitants et assassiné et elle meurt
dans l'explosion de sa d'une bombe qui
était placée sous le siège de sa voiture
sous le passager avant et juste avant
elle parlait avec son fils Matthew qui
est un pote à moi que je connaissais
déjà depuis quelques années qui
travaillait à l'ci en fait qui était
développeur là-bas l' IG c'est le
consortium international des
journalistes d'investigation qui
derrière les Panama papers et daphneé
était une journaliste peut-être la
dernière journaliste de cette île de ce
pays euh tout le monde connaissait c'est
Daphné mal c'est c'est trois quatre
familles et elle avait un blog qui
s'appelait running commentary qui avait
300000 connexions unique par mois sur
une île de 400000 habitants donc elle
était très suivie tout le monde venait
lui parler et elle était détestée par
tout le monde et un jour il y avait un
policier même un commissaire qui avait
dit si un jour daphneé est tué on est
bien dans la merde parce qu'elle a
tellement d'ennemis on va pas savoir par
où commencer puis elle a été tuée elle
avait dit à son fils je au centrreeville
et son
fils était a remis ses ses écouteurs
écouta la musique sur son ordinateur et
puis il a entendu une énorme
déflagration un énorme
boom deux ou 3 minutes après il est
descendu sur la petite route elle vit un
peu à la campagne reculée à Malte et il
a vu sa voiture en flamme et sa mère
dans les flammes déjà mortes et ça ça se
passe en Europe au sein de l'Union
européenne et le lendemain de ça j'ai
une conversation avec Matthew pour le
dire je viens juste de créer forbidon
stories c'est une organisation et notre
mission c'est tout simple on fait du
journalisme et on poursuit le travail
des reporters assassinés
et et je rentrai de passer une année
justement aux États-Unis où j'avais
gagné un fellowhip une bourse pour
pouvoir développer et créer forbident
stories qui la bourse c'est le Night
Wallas Fellowship à l'Université du
Michigan a aux États-Unis tu trois
universités qui font ça depuis 60 ans
Stanford Harvard et Michigan et qui
propose à 12 journalistes par an venu du
monde entier enfin essentiellement des
États-Unis il prennent deux trois
étrangers de venir si tu as une idée sur
le journalisme qui peut changer quelque
chose sur l'accès à l'information il te
sélectionne tu dois savoir la pitcher en
10 mots en 500 mots faire un oral et
puis si tu es prix la chance c'est que
il t'offre en fait du temps de cerveau
disponible et et un salaire et et j'y
suis allé avec ma femme n deux enfants
et une expérience et un salaire normal
pour pas d'argent pour développer le
projet mais tu passes du temp au moins à
te concentrer sur ça et c'est un
fellowhip pour des journalistes en
milieu de carrière c'est le moment où
ton cerveau commence à être brûlé un peu
par les deadlines par les pressions par
plein de choses et où tu et c'est une
chance géniale parce que tu as 1 an de
réflexion pour
porter un projet qui était cher et moi
mon projet qui était cher c'était
celui-là c'était créer une organisation
mondiale don notre notre mission serait
la suivante on poursuivrait les enquêtes
des reporters assassinés et ce sera une
façon de de de donner un accès à l'info
et deux de dire au tueur vous voyez
c'est absolument contreproductif pour
revenir sur daphneé juste donc j'ai eu
Matthew le lendemain d'autres
journalistes du du gardian du Z ch
avaient appelé Matth
et et on lui a proposé de poursuivre le
travail de sa maman et il a dit il y a
qu'une seule chose qui compte qui est le
plus important aujourd'hui c'est de
poursuivre le travail de ma mère donc on
s'est retrouvé à 45 pas seulement
européen le New York Times proposé au
New York Times de de venir mais aussi
c'était le monde en France la suite de
l'investigation de Radio France et puis
le gardien en Angleterre on a travaillé
à 45 18 organisations de presse et on
a créé plusieurs équipes et c'est comme
ça qu'on fait à chaque fois on met une
équipe sur le meurtre collecter des
indices sur le meurtre donc essayer
d'avoir des sources auprès de la police
est-ce qu'il y a des des CC TV des
caméras qui ont filmé ça est-ce que on a
accès à la messagerie WhatsApp de la
personne encore pour voir s'il y avait
des menaces qui av été reçues est-ce que
sur l'ordinateur portable on a le mot de
passe pour pouvoir voir quels étaient
les derniers sujets ou si la personne
avait reçu des messages de menace
diter s'il y a un trop gent dessus ouais
ou absolument ce qu'on a fait plusieurs
fois euh de faire faire des analyses
avec on travaille beaucoup avec avec
Citizen Lab et Amnesty international
security Lab qui sont deux organisations
qui font euh de des analyses forensiques
c'estàd ils analyses en fait les
appareils pour voir s'il y a des s'ils
sont inf ou pas par des virus ou par des
des logiciels espion euh et et donc
Daphné on a enquêté sur son meurtre elle
avait reçu peu de temps avant sa mort un
li une fite de données
euh d'un d'une société qui s'appelait
lectrogaz et qui est une société qui
fournissait le le l'électricité
l'énergie à à Nice à Nice à à Malte et
je pas pareus ouais j'étais en vacances
à Nice il y a pas longtemps c'est pour
ça euh et donc elle avait reçu un énorme
li on a traité le li on a vu les infos
qui étaient dedans et euh et on a
enquêté sur plein de pistes différentes
on a poursuivi le travail de daphneé et
parmi le groupe de 45 journalistes
certains ont réussi à identifier en fait
les personnes elle enquêtait en
particulier sur un sujet c'était deux
membes du gouvernement qui avait un
compte qui avait été révélé dans les
Panama papers et ce compte en banque
devait être alimenté par une autre
société qui s'appelait sente black et le
tout était de savoir qui était derrière
S7 black et nos journalistes ont réussi
à savoir qui était derrière se black
c'était un gars qui s'appelait jgen
fenek qui a été qui poursuivi
aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs personnes
donc inculpé à c'était il y a 7 ans
impliqué dans le meurtre de daphneé et
en
fait c'était de l'argent qui devait être
versé c'était des rétrocommissions qui
devaiit être versé en échange de de ce
marché de l'électricité fourni à
d'autres et c'est ce consortium
d'électricité était avec plusieurs
actionnaires dont l'État d'azerbaïan qui
est un pays que je connais bien qui m'a
poursuivi en justice qui m'a arrêté
là-bas euh et tout mais donc voilà tout
ça pour dire qu'on a poursuivi l'enquête
de daphneé à plusieurs ça a eu un impact
euh pas seulement l'enquête
journalistique mais il y a eu aussi dis
le FBI s'est mêlé à l'enquête judiciaire
menée par les autorités maltaises le
Premier ministre a été poussé à la
démission le chef de cabinet était
impliqué dans dans dans toute cette
chaîne au-dessus des des tueurs il a été
et il est inquiété encore les deux
frères des Georgio qui ont posé la bombe
sont sous les verrous ont expliquer que
c'était un business as usual ils avaient
accepté pour 150000 € d'aller poser une
bombe c'était des tueurs ils avaient
sans doute tué avant euh et à Malte ça
se trouve assez facilement ce genre de
de profil là donc donc nous notre job
c'est ça en fait c'est on enquête pour
savoir qui est derrière le meurtre et on
poursuit le travail pour faire en sorte
que les gens aient accès aux infos sur
lesquel travailler daphneé par
exemple est-ce que vous avez subi ou
forbidon story est-ce que vous avez subi
des tentatives
d'infiltration que ce soit physique ou
numérique par qui comment comment ça se
passe alors
alors physique c'est un journaliste qui
est en fait piloté non mais par X ou Y
pour savoir ce qui se passe chez vous ou
ouais ça il y a des demandes de stage
qui sont plus louges que d'autres
c'est-à-dire plus louges que d'autres
plus louges que d'autres parce que les
personnes sont trop gradées pour
demander un stage c'est trop bizarre
exemple euh non mais des profils très
internationaux
euh j'ai un j'ai un souvenir d'une
journaliste russe euh
mais qui avait une autre nationalité qui
avait un parcours je crois à LSI à
Londres et un peu de sciancep en France
Mo s'appelit non je sais je sais je sais
pas c'était il y a 3 ans ou 4 ans
ressemblit à quoi bah je je sais pas une
mais en tout cas il y a des profils
comme ça qui ressemblent pas à des
profils qu'on reçoit d'habitude est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres profils du genre
israélien marocains cataris saoudien
français ou ou vénézuen américain
ouiique d'infiltration physique parce à
ma
connaissance pas à ma connaissance pas
ma connaissance après quand on a
travaillé sur le sujet de Pegasus et
donc là c'était c'était très complexe en
terme de Risk Assessment j'ouvre une
parenthèse juste pour rebondir sur la
journalist et la nana elle avit
peut-être un gros CV mais elle voulait
simplement bosser pour essayer de
d'améliorer les choses ouais peut-être
mais on a eu d'autres cas comme ça aussi
où à la fin on fait choix on se dit non
là ça ça ça
euh
ça il vaut mieux pas et vous expliquez
votre choix et votre choix est compris
euh non on l'explique pas comme ça juste
on base et on passe et on prend
quelqu'un qu'on qu'on voit en entretien
plusieurs fois et on explique aussi les
règles de confidentialité quand on
rejoint forbidon stories on explique les
règles aussi de comportement sur nos
téléphone nos appareils quel voilà des
règles un peu de base de d'hygiène euh
numérique on explique ça après on a sur
la sécurité c'est un vrai sujet qui
force à l'humilité sincèrement parce que
au final on est des journalistes on
n'est pas du tout formé on n'est pas des
militaires on n pas des moyens militaire
on a on a ce qu'on peut trouver où ce
qui nous est conseillé par Citizen Lab
par Amnesty security Lab euh on a on
utilise que ce qu'on nous dit d'utiliser
euh et et ça je parle de la là pour le
coup de la sécurité notre surface
d'attaque et de notre sécurité euh
digitale numérique de nos instances
quoi c'est très intéressant ce que tu
dis on n'est pas des militaires ou alors
euh j'ai j'ai deux j'ai deux
lectures j'ai un la lecture des des mecs
de la DGSE qui se baladent avec des
mondes connectés en OPEX et le numéro 2
qui se fait remonter jusqu'en bas de
chez lui ou qui sont sur STVA donc là
qui sont sur St On dit bonjour à
Monsieur Manac et et donc on n'est pas
des militaires donc moi ça me fait
rigoler mais ce que je voulais dire par
là c'est qu'on a pas des on a pas de
moyens on n pas des téléphones
Talès et on n pas 25 personnes de la de
qui ont fait 10 ans d'études au
ministère de la Défense pour nous
fournir des appareils de chiffrement
donc on travaille et l'organisation
d'dir Snowden on travaille avec Claudio
garnierie de de Amnesty security Lab qui
est celui qui a piloté tout le projet
NSO sur l'entreprise donc israélienne
NSO qui vend le logiciel Pegasus on
avait pas un ancien ambassadeur de
France qui était au bord de sac si si
mais comment il s'appelait ce cet
ambassadeur si si comment c'est quoi son
petit prénom Gérard har comment Gérard
Harrow qui était mais il a démissionné
du bord ouais on l'a interrogé là-dessus
alors euh parce que c'était quand même
très
embêtant très embêtant d'avoir donc
Gérard pour ceux qui connaissent pas
était un et je pense que beaucoup de
gens le connaissent parce qu'il est
quand même invité sur plein de plateaux
et il peut délivrer des opinions pour le
coup très intéressante mais il était
quand même membre du Board d'une société
qui s'appelle NSO group il savait
peut-être pas je je me fais il savait
très bien je pense qu'il savait très
bien qu'il a il a été je pense c'est pas
mon problème il a en tout cas il savait
qu'il était membre de ce bord d'une
entreprise de qui fait la
cyberersurveillance qui vend des
logiciels espion à des états comme
l'Azerbaïdjan le Mexique ou l'Arabie
Saoudite il savaient ça et et il a je
trouve ça assez incroyable quand on est
quand on représente la France et qu'on a
été même son représentant de la France
aux États-Unis qu'on accepte ensuite de
siéger au bord d'une entreprise comme
NSO group alors après NSO group dit oui
mais on vend ce logiciel là pour lutter
contre le terrorisme pour lutter contre
les méchants et pour les attraper ça
c'est ce qu'on raconte aux enfants la
réalité c'est que ce logiciel là il est
utilisé par des États qui ont une très
mauvaise réputation en matière de droits
de l'homme et qui et qui traquent les
journalistes les dissidents tous ceux
qui les dérangent avec ça et qui a
surtout et c'est c'est tout le problème
de la cybersillance aucun contre pouvoir
c'est le Far West absolu et c'est et
c'est une économie ultra résiliente nous
on a révélé le projet Pegasus le
scandale Pegasus avec on a eu accès à
50000 numéos de téléphone
potentiellement visés par Pegasus on a
révélé ça ça a eu un quelques impacts
les États-Unis ont blacklisté NSO Group
et ont interdit à toute entreprise
américaine de de commercer avec
l'entreprise NSO group il y a eu des
commissions d'enquête au niveau européen
il y a eu la Cour suprême en Inde un
diligent aussi des enquêtes Gérard r
était peut-être pas au courant de tout
ça mais si il était au courant de tout
ça on on l' nous on l'a rencontré Gérard
Aro et qu'est-ce qu'il a dit et ben il a
dit
euh il était gêné
embêté il dit moi j'étais pas au courant
de des abus qui pouvaient être fait
j'avais peu peu d'information m'était
donné tout à fait concevable bah non
c'est pas concevable c'est en fait ce
qui on peut pas siéger au bord de d'une
entreprise de cyber sururveillance
leader dans le monde sans se poser la
question de est-ce que à un moment donné
ce logiciel là il va pas être utilisé
pour tuer la démocratie quelque part
voir partout c'est pas concevable du
tout enfin c'est pas concevable chacun
fait ce qu'il veut c'était sans doute
légal c'est juste que il a quitté euh
cette fonctionl je pense parce qu' suite
à nos révélations parce qu'il était
honnête gêné et honnête mais oui ouais
en tout cas il a quitté voilà mais mais
il y avait d'autres personnes membres du
bord là je les ai plus en tête mais il y
avait avait des anciens de la diplomatie
américaine qui avaent qui siégeai au
bord donc après les membership de ces
enfin l'appartenance à ces bord parfois
c'est je vais dans ce bord là parce que
un tali est aussi donc c'est safe c'est
pas trop dangereux et tout mais
l'intérêt pour un asso d'avoir quelqu'un
comme Gérard Haro membre de ce bord là
il est énorme c'est c'est de dire
ensuite au saoudien écoutez on a même
l'ancien ambassadeur de France aux
États-Unis la France vous le savez très
bien c'est la patrie des Droits de
l'Homme donc ça c'est ce que NSO va dire
au saoudien ou ailleurs qui est dans
notre bord donc vous inquiétez pas sur
la gestion de réputation de crise on a
un bord qui nous protège de ça et les
bord ça sert à ça dans ces entreprises
très sensibles qui vendent de de la de
la Cyb surveillance à des des états
comme ça donc Les Bordes ça sert à voilà
à endormir un peu à raconter ça aux
enfants pour dire qu'on on travaille
pour choper des terroristes euh mais
après après voilà le sujet de
il est majeur le sujet la cberveillance
il est majeur il est parce qu'il y a
aucun moyen pour nous sincèrement à ce
jour en tant que citoyen de se défendre
et c'est grave c'est pas il y a quelques
moyens pas franchement je accessible
plus difficilement mais à quelques mois
non mais de ouais mais je suis d'une
nature optimiste globalement mais
là-dessus et pour avoir travaillé
beaucoup sur le sujet oui bien sûr on
peut aussi se dire on touche plus à un
seul téléphone un seul ordi et tout ce
qui se branche sur du secteur ouais
voilà sauf que quand on veut faire ce
métier de journaliste ce métier d'avocat
ce métier de militant des droits de
l'homme et ben il faut ce métier de
président de la République ou ce métier
de président de laépublque ou ce métier
de ministre de la défance ouis non
maisite le président de la République il
a un téléphone euh qu'il est fourni par
les militaires qu'il est censé être qui
est utiliser mais juste je parle du
militant des droits de l'homme qui est
au fin fond de Mexico City et qui veut
organiser une manifestation contre la
corruption de son pays bah il va
forcément créer une groupe un groupe
WhatsApp depuis son téléphone il va
télgram euh il va peut-être utiliser
telgram où c'est pas chiffré de bout en
bout et et les informations se peuvent
être euh données facilement mais Pegasus
était plus fort que signal ou que
tellgram Pegasus le principe juste pour
ceux qui ne savent pas c'est que c'est
un un logiciel qui s'installe à distance
en zéro clic c'estàd qu' il y avait à
une époque il fallait cliquer sur un
lien malveillant pour faire
s'autoinstaller le le logiciel et puis à
partir de 2017-28 ils ont développé le
zéro clic c'estàdire que en fait tu
t'endormais ton téléphone était à côté
sur ta table de chevet tu te réveillais
le matin le téléphone était toujours là
sauf que tu étais infecté et puis tu
avais une batterie qui avait descendu
beaucoup plus rapidement euh pas pas
c'était pas si sûr que ça tu peux avoir
des anomalies ça dépender des modèles de
téléphone ça c'est pas si certain que ça
on l'a pas vérifié à chaque fois parce
qu'on a fait beaucoup de forensic
beaucoup d'analyses sur ces téléphone là
et on a trouvé des traces d'infection
avec les équipes d'amnestie sécurtilable
mais cette l'ire du Zéro clic c'estàd
que plus besoin d'envoyer un texto
malveillant a changé la donne ça a
permis à plein d'états de se de se dire
on achète cette solution là Pegasus il y
a pas que Pegasus sur le marché mais on
achète ent cette solution là parce qu'il
y a aucun risque pour nous pour de se
faire choper et c'est comme ça que le
que le militant activiste à Mexico qui
veut lutter contre la la corruption ben
lui il a forcément besoin d'un groupe
WhatsApp pour mobiliser ses militants il
va forcément dire à momenté le but de la
manif c'est de dire ça et on se retrouve
à telle heure mais il peut se faire
assassiner aussi à cette heure-là
précisément parce qu'il est suivi à la
trace à cause ou grâce au logiciel
espion Pegasus une fois installé sur le
téléphone c'est fini c'estàd que il
c'est un logiciel qui active tout en
fait le micro la caméra qui va c'est de
c'est de l'opération très chirurgicale
faut pas imaginer c'est pas un système
de surveillance massif qui tourne sur
des millions de gens c'est de la
chirurgie avec un opérateur de
renseignement qui est derrière qui se
dit tiens aujourd'hui je vais sur le
téléphone de Sky j'y vais de 14 à 16h
parce que à 17h je suis sur telle
personne et mon but du du jour c'est de
choper tout le répertoire de mot de
passe de Skype par exemple ou euh tout
son carnet photo vidéo et ça c'est
collecté et puis c'est filé un autre
chef du renseignement qui va ensuite ite
bâtir un
dossier pendant des années peut-être sur
une personne pour un jour éventuellement
en avoir besoin euh donc nous quand on a
enquêté sur Pegasus on est parti avec
une liste de 50000 numéros qui n'étaient
pas tous infectés qui étaient
potentiellement infectés en fait c'était
les numéros qui étaient rentrés par les
clients de NSO sur le terminal qui était
fourni par NSO dans l'interface NSO et
après il décidait d'infecter ou pas céit
un process d'infection en plusieurs
étapes et quand il décid d'infecter ben
en comment il choper les numéros de
téléphone par phonebook non mais en fait
c'est ça va très vite parce que dès que
tu chopes le numéro de téléphone de
quelqu'un tu chopes son d'adresse et
donc et surtout il map en fait si je
rentre dans ton téléphone enfin si ils
rentrent dans ton téléphone ils vont
tout de suite voir tes contacts les plus
fréquents et à partir de tes contacts
fréquents ils vont ils vont essayer de
te raconter de se dire mais quelles sont
les personnes qui voient le
plus quels sont ses sour à qui à qui ce
journaliste a parlé ce jour-là je suis
pas journaliste non non mais par exemple
à qui quelle est la source en général
une bonne question qu'il faut se poser
aussi par rapport à l'appréciation du
risque comment c'est souvent une
question que tu poses dans tes
interviews qui est importante c'est
comment vous les journalistes vous
protéger une question qui est
essentielle c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut
protéger parce que le but de ce qu'on
fait c'est de rendre publique une chose
que l'on trouve qui est un abus qui une
histoire et c'est très important de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on veut protéger
parce que en fonction de cette
hiérarchie tu peux changer de moyen de
protection ou adapter ta protection par
rapport à l'importance du secret qu'il
faut protéger le truc qui est-ce que
vous êtes
gentil vous êtes gentil Bour quand même
non mais non c'est pas bisounours parce
que pour le coup ce qui a le plus
important à protéger c'est la vie de la
personne qui te parle ça c'est pas
bisounours protéger ta source protéger
ta source c'est pas bisounours du tout
c'estd que c'est
euh le la première conversation entre
une source et un journaliste c'est le
moment
décisif c'est pour ça qu'il est
d'ailleurs conseillé d'indiquer à toute
personne qui veut rentrer en contact de
quel façon c'est plus sécure de rentrer
en contact avec toi donc c'est pas
bisounours du tout
c'est Lux leak c'est Antoine Deltour et
Raphaël alleé qui sont poursuivis
pendant des années avec les huissiers
envoyés par Stéphan Gibou voilà ou
d'autres qui ont leur vie boul verersé
c'est d'autres qui vont partir en prison
parce que la conversation n'a pas été
sécurisée
au départ donc qu'est-ce que moi je veux
protéger quand je suis journ
investigation comment je me protège en
fait la réponse elle est ultra complexe
alors ceux qui disent utilise cette
application c'est 100 % safe sont des
menteurs ne jamais les croire ou des des
connards oui ou alors des gens qui
veulent le le ce qui est safe
aujourd'hui ce qui est sécure
aujourd'hui ne le sera pas forcément
demain euh tu connais la phrase non
vas-y quand il y a un doute il n'y a pas
de dout plus
doutoutou donc
donc moi ce que je conseille toujours au
jour ave lesquel je travaille c'est
c'est d'évaluer le risque déjà au nom
des personnes avec lesquelles on est en
contact nous on travaille dans des pays
où les gourn sont assassinés c'est le
propre de forbidden stories et donc le
on parle à des collègues de ces
journalistes là qui sont encore en vie
tu parles je suis désolé j'essaie de
dynamiser un peu le truc et tu parles à
des journalistes qui qui sont menacés de
mort ainsi de suite est-ce que tu parles
à des journalistes qui sont planqués
dans les salles de rédaction qui ont
levé un truc un petit peu qui se font
emmerder par leurs collègues pour se
taire qui se font merd par leur r chef
pour se taire parce que ça c'est c'est
pas une mort physique on est quand même
en France ce serait quand même un petit
peu ça sa vraie tâche donc on leur
impose la mort médiatique
ouais mais du coup tu veux dire quoi par
là est-ce que tu discute avec des
journalistes par exemple français bien
sûr mais moi je discute avec des
journalistes qui étaient dans un média
qui a été ensuite par Boré qui sont
retrouvés finalement à la porte la
situation en France c'est aussi ça je
discute avec des journalistes qui
peuvent être censurés parce que
effectivement le un gars concerné par un
sujet dans ton émission tu as reçu plein
de témoignages comme ça
euh veut pas que le sujet passe donc ça
peut arriver je je je pense que on a en
France après on a miapart on a le monde
il y a des services d'investigation dans
on a disclose on a for on a plein on a
on a quand même quand on voyage un peu
on se rend compte on a en France quand
même un écosystème de la presse qui
permet de sortir de l'info ça c'est sûr
d'accord une fois qu'on a sorti
l'info ça touche la population comment
ça lu en touche une sans faire bouger
l'autre ça c'est c'est ça fait quoi ils
sont tellement attends je pas fini ils
sont en catatonie émotionnelle parce qu'
sont emmerdés avec leur boulot le risque
économique les problèmes avec les
enfants à l'école quand il y a encore un
prof à l'école la population est-ce
qu'elle est pas tellement saturée
d'infos de télénovella médiatique payé
ou organisé par des journalistes que
vous votre travail de moine bénédictin
ébéniste appelle ça comme tu veux bon
d'accord c'est un petit peu de caviar
jeté au cochon ah faut pas dire ça je le
fais exprès je sais mais moi je réponds
ça exprès parce que c'est important de
le répondre exprès parce que j'entends
beaucoup ça et c'est
euh je dis pas seulement ça parce que au
quotidien mon travail consiste avec
toute l'équipe de forbon stories et tous
nos partenaires à poursuivre les
enquêtes de gens qui ont pris une balle
dans la tête donc faut pas l'oublier une
balle dans la tête c'est bien quand même
parce qu'il y a pire qu'une balle dans
la tête ouais alors je vais pas je vais
pas épiloguer là-dessus mais si si j'is
bien que tu épilogues non mais oui il y
a des il y a des goural tortur non bien
sûr non mais je suis d'accord enfin ce
que je veux dire c'est que torturer
comment non mais il y a des journalist
torturés il y a des journalistes comment
bah il y a des journalistes on leur
coupe les doigts on envoie le doigt à la
famille on leur arrache un œil on
commence par l'oreilleou au Mexique il y
a des vidéos de journalistes qui sont
enlevés et batttu frappés devant des
caméras et les vidéos sont envoyées sont
posté sur les réseaux sociaux si si non
non ça c'est genre c'est Guantanamo
amélioré ah ouais ouais vraiment donc
non il y a des journalistes qui sont
euh on travaille avec une journaliste au
Mexique elle elle a été kidnappée
pendant 3 jours euh battu ils ont non
elle a pas été abusée mais ils ont
récupéré son ordinateur ils l'ont menacé
elle a été batue elle est en fait je
crois qu'elle elle rent ils avaient ils
l'ont piégé dans un VI un chauffeur de
taxi a rentré dans un taxi en fait le
chauffeur de taxi était aux mains d'un
cartel ils l'ont euh et un cartel ça
veut tout et rien dire en réalité c'est
souvent ce qu'on appelle au Mexique la
zone grise c'estàd que c'est là où se
retrouve bah des élus politiques des
barons de la drogue et une
administration globalement corrompue et
ce qui ce qui tue les journalistes mais
pas seulement les journalistes les
militants des droits de l'homme et tout
ça au Mexique c'est le niveau de
corruption qui qui provoque un taux
d'impunité qui dépasse les 92 % ou 90 %
c'est CPJ qui est une organisation
américaine commit to protect journalist
fait chaque ané un index de l'impunité
c'est F ça aussi en France euh ils le
font sur le nombre de sur le le nombre
de journalistes tués euh
donc en France ils sont plus malins en
France ouais en France en tout cas il y
a on peut tuer l'information on peut
tuer le message on peut il y a des
journalistes on peut acheter un
journaliste on a révélé avec le projet
story killers euh l'affaire Rachid
embarquy je sais pas si tu connais mais
on a là on travaille donc sur la
désinformation
et ça se passe et en une équipe membre
de notre consortium de journalistes de
haretz en Israel plus Frédéric metzo qui
travaille à la cellule investigation de
Radio France et qui nous rejoint en
rédacteur en chef maintenant à forbidon
stories ont infiltré
une une cellule qui se faisait appeler
team roré
et
qui prétendait avoir manipulé dans pas
mal de de pays des élections euh des
scrutins ou manipuler
l'information dans des phases de scrutin
et c'était les mecs ne montraient pas
leur visage et Frédéric metzo s'est fait
passer pour un intermédiaire agissant au
nom d'un président africain et les
conversations ont lieu d'abord en visio
avec une la personne en face qui
montrait pas son visage et Frédéric et
aidé par Homer et Gour qui était deux
journalistes israéliens qui travailler
ensemble à cette infiltration a dit
voilà moi j'aimerais faire je crois
repousser
l'élection dans mon pays là je voudrais
créer le bordel dans dans dans ce pays
comment je peux faire et en face on lui
dit et il sait pas qui lui parle et tout
l'objet de l'enquête va être ensuite de
savoir qui est derrière Tim roré et qui
se cache derrière ça et est-ce qu'ils
sont en train de bluffer est-ce qu'ils
font vraiment ce qu'ils disent qu'il
font et Frédéric mzo lui fait parler et
lui dit mais vous avez des preuves de ce
que vous faites comment vous manipulez
les élections qu'est-ce que vous faites
exactement et il lui explique ben nous
on fait du par exemple du Haen Leck euh
on on fait c'est un service qui est de
plus en plus d'ailleurs il y a une étude
d'Oxford je crois de 2019 qui a établi
que euh alors peut-être il faut que soit
fa checké mais je crois 45 États avaient
eu recours à plus de 80 boîtes privées
pour pratiquer de la désinformation à
grande échelle dans des phases de
scrutin euh une étude intéressante
d'Oxford faut vérifier les chiffres mais
c'est ça raconte les boîtes elles sont
issues de quel pays et les boîtes il y
en a en Inde il y en a en Israël il y en
a en Europe de l'est sans doute en
France je sais pas j'en sais je je aux
États-Unis un peu
euh je sais pas sincèrement je sais plus
en tout cas nous on a travaillé
précisément sur une boîte qui était
devant nous et qui disait faire ça et
l'enquête menée par les partenaires de
fortbidon était franchement hyper
intéressante parce qu'il lu a dit dit
alors vous pouvez me prouver et il dit
ok nous on fait du Hack and le opération
il dit ok c'est quoi mais par exemple ce
que je peux faire pour vous et je peux
le faire en live parce qu'après ils les
ont rencontré en vrai avec une caméra
cachée
euh je vais hacker le compte telégram du
conseiller de William Ruto qui est le
président du du Kenya ce conseiller là
et j'ai oublié le nom du conseiller et
euh il fait la démonstration en live et
il montre le compte telgram actuel avec
les conversations l'historique de
conversation et notre notre journaliste
voit ça et 3 l' dure assez longtemps
mais 3 mois après on a pris contact avec
le conseiller pour dire est-ce que ce
jour-là vous aviez ça et ça pour avoir
plein de points de repère pour vérifier
que le gars nous faisait pas une
interface bidon et C fait ton job
c'était vrai pour le coup c'est pas moi
qui l'ai fait mais c'était Fred metzo
puis l'équipe du monde aussi qui avait
beaucoup participé à deuxième truc qui
avait été fait pour
tester cette équipe là team roré pour
savoir s blleuffit ou pas on leur a dit
euh par qu'il disit nous on peut créer
des des hashtags qui vont vraiment euh
devenir tendance on dit bon mais est-ce
qu'on peut faire un essai il dit oui
dites-nous un hashtag et puis on va
essayer de le faire monter un peu le
truc a plus ou moins marché il est un
peu monté mais c'est intéressant parce
que ça nous a permis de découvrir autre
chose l'équipe euh l'équipe de forbidden
a dit ok est-ce que vous pouvez créer un
hashtag RIP Emmanuel le Emmanuel en
question c'était pas Emmanuel Macron
c'était de à l'époque ouais c'était non
c'était un c'était un
un e c'est une une forme d'autruche j'ai
découvert ce nom là à ce moment-là et
qui faisait le buzz sur Twitter à
l'époque où la fille qui qui était en
Australie je crois qui élevait cet AE là
elle le filmait avec une GoPro et elle
lui disait toujours elle le filmait et
elle disait don do that Emmanuel elle
essayait de casser avec son bec l'écran
de la GoPro elle dis non don't do that
Emmanuel et ça c'était retweeté mais des
millions de fois ou des centaines
milliers de fois et c'était ça faisait
le buzz et l'équipe de forbidon a dit
bon ben est-ce qu'on peut faire croire
que cet meu est mort et faire un RIP
Emmanuel juste pour voir si ça marche ou
pas et ils ont dit ok on le fait et ils
ont fait un RIP Emmanuel qui a un peu
monté qui a été repartagé je sais plus
peut-être une centaine de fois ou 200
fois l'éleveuse le lendemain matin elle
s'est réveillée avec le décalage horaire
elle elle a reçu plein de messages elle
a communiqué après làdessus plus tard je
crois qu'elle avait interviewé pant
consortium parce que elle s'est tout le
monde lui disait on est désolé pour toi
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il est mort
Emmanuel et tout elle a foncé dans son
champ là où elle avait clôturé Emmanuel
elle a vu qu' était en vue elle a fait
une preuve de vie d'Emmanuel elle a dit
non elle a fait un communiqué pour dire
je sais pas ce qui se passe il y a une
désinformation mais mon émeux est
vraiment vivant et nous c'était hyper
intéressant parce que tous les comptes
qui ont été activés pour relayer l'info
en fait l'équipe du monde a bossé
ensuite un mois dessus pour les mapper
et pour savoir où est-ce qu'ils avaient
été utilisés avant et je sais sa plus
mais je crois qu'il av é utilisé aux
Philippines sur des campagnes pour
dénigrer rappleur par exemple sur la
campagne des élections présidentiel 2016
aussi des trucs comme ça et donc on
voyait en fait l'armée de troll tu sais
que tu peux faire la même chose en
France ouais bien sûr mais non mais
c'était donc et d'ailleurs je vais venir
à l'exemple français ensuite donc ça
c'était juste pour donner une anecdote
de de et aussi qui est pas seulement
rigolote parce que c'était un qui est
gravissime parce que ça raconte la
puissance de ces boîtes qui pratiquent
la désinformation à une are à une
échelle industrielle
et le la personne qui se faisait donc
appeler roré de cette équipe team roré
dit aussi à notre équipe mais vous savez
dans votre pays je pratique aussi ça
m'est déjà arrivé j'ai quelques contacts
et je pratique aussi des
informations dit ah bon montrez-nous et
dit bah regardz cette vidéo là
euh c'était alors je me souviens plus de
C c'est pas une vidéo sur le un port au
un port dans un pays et ça faisait la
promo d'une d'un port dans un d'une
autorité portuaire ou d'une boîte dans
un P euh cette vidéo là regardez elle
est passée sur BFM plusieurs fois et
tout et dit on est derrière ça je peux
pas vous dire quel est le client mais
c'est passé comme ça les tarifs
euh les tarifs au
final donc juste je raconte l'histoire
parce que les tarifs on les a découverts
par l'enquête judiciaire après
mais le la vidéo était passée donc
plusieurs fois sur BFM TV Frédéric metzo
a appelé Marc Olivier faogel pour dire
on enquête sur une vidéo qui a un
parcours un peu bizarre comment elle est
arrivé chez toi comment est arrivé chez
et euh et puis il y a une enquête de
diligenté au sein de BFM TV pour savoir
pourquoi cette vidéo là é passée et elle
était passée un jour genre à minuit ou
minuit 10 et le présentateur s'appelait
Rachid
arkiy et en fait abfm euh le
présentateur est arrivé a pris l'antenne
et personne ne savait exactement mais
qui avait mis concrètement la vidéo en
régie finale enfin il faut une carte SD
où il faut une clé il faut pluguer
quelque chose il faut et euh technicien
il faut un technicien et tout je sais
pas quelle est le fin mot là-dessus de
qui a mis le truc ou si c'est lui qui a
mis la clé euh s y avait la compétence
technique pour faire ça je sais pas
toujours est-il que il a reconnu avoir
passé cette fait passer cette vidéo làà
dans son journal pour rendre service à
un ami et il a bord j'ai jamais touché
d'argent et puis l'enquête et puis il a
été mise en examen et il est toujours
mise en examen il y a eu des révélations
qui où je crois qu'il a admis de
lui-même dans une audition que il avait
touché 4000 ou 5000 € pour pour ça il y
a une chaîne d'intermédiaire avant qui
ont dû peut-être prendre 400 500 € pour
ça voilà donc ça c'est c'était
intéressant ce projet team roray ce
projet story killers où on a rêvé
l'existence de team roray parce que on
voyait à la fois d'un côté même
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle pour pratiquer la
désinformation et le ses opération hcken
leak et en même temps la vieille le
vieux circuit euh qui peut exister qui a
créé des remou à BFM TV et je pense que
sincèrement je veux absolument pas
donner l'impression de dire que c'est
euh euh extrêmement répandu je pense que
ça reste exceptionnel et de ce que je
connais de ce que je vois c'est
exceptionnel mais on l'a révélé et euh
et c'était important de le révéler et la
personne est mise en examin donc donc
c'était beaucoup beaucoup d'enquête sur
ce trucl beaucoup pardon de sur sur ce
type de de d'infiltration de ménage de
journalistes tu en as fait beaucoup
est-ce que tu as fait beaucoup de
salalles de rédaction est-ce que tu as
fait le pédigré de tous les gens qui
étaient là-bas y compris dans les médias
télévisuels des techniciens
ouais mais est-ce que est-ce que alors
certes les journalistes se font
infiltrer par la pas guain ou par
stupidité mais toi tu as la preuve de ça
qu'ils se font infiltrer par la p je te
pose la question ah je crois que tu
disais ça non deuxième question c'est
les techniciens est-ce que vous regardez
qui fait quoi qui comment est-ce que par
exemple une erreur d'un technicien qui
permet de faire réagir
l'arcom est-ce que vous allez regarder
en détail
euh je vais parler de ce que je connais
à
à quand j'ai travaillé à cache
investigation on on travaille sur des
enquêtes sensible ou à pièce à
conviction ou même à forb stories on
fait toujours très attention à qui
travaille avec avec nous et quel est
le et de faire en sorte qu'on soit pas
infiltré qu'il ait pas de corruption qui
donc on y fait attention sur la question
des de ce que j'ai pu voir moi ce que
franchement ce que je dirais sur à quoi
comment est l'écosystème journalistique
en France par rapport à ces questions de
corruption
toi tu parles de cast tu et tout je sais
pas si c'est une cast ce que je vois
c'est qu'il y a une précarisation c'est
vrai tu sais comment on fait obéir un
chien non dis-moi ça sert à rien de lui
taper dessus affemmele juste un petit
peu ouais après il oublie bien peut-être
ce qui est sûr c'est que
euh ce qui est sûr c'est que parfois
souvent l'État ne nous aide pas je peux
donner un exemple qui a à voir avec la
cybers surveillance euh
et qui vous êtes pas vous avez une niche
fiscale non non attends je non mais je
peux te dire un truc sur la cyber
surveillance c'est que la France fait
partie des rares pays à avoir poussé au
niveau européen pour qu'on puisse
espionner légalement les journalistes
pour toi tu débarques toi non mais elle
a poussé mais officiellement non je
débarque pas je je vois quelque chose
qui est scandaleux euh et qu'on a
dénoncé à plusieurs pour et finalement
c'est pas passé mais la France euh qui
euh ton interprétation c'est pourquoi
ils font ça parce que quand même merde
parceon est on est dans mais parce qu'on
est dans un pays qui a un euh ton
interprétation de ça mon interprétation
c'est que on vit on vit connais la
guerre économique un peu je sais pas je
je je connais la guerre de l'info euh je
connais la guerre de l'info je connais
la guerre des moyens euh de l'info je
connais effectivement cette la
précarisation du milieu journalistique
et je sais euh
et je sais et je sais qu'elles peuvent
être nous limite mais je sais aussi
qu'elles peuvent être les efforts de
plein de journalistes à disclose à
Médiapart ailleurs pour sortir des truc
éipén disclose miapart c'est des ovnis
ben quand quand mediapart révèle
l'affaire kahusac c'est pas un
épiphénomène kusac s'en va il y a pardon
mais le journalisme ça sert à des trucs
hein parfois ça sert ça révèle il faut
fâche-toi fâche-toi non mais je je me
fâche pas mais juste un truc le le le
journalisme c'est pas c'est pas juste
c'est pas juste
une c'est pas juste un bien pour
lesgendé c'est pour en fait on fait on
travaille pour qui on appelle ça le 4è
pouvoir ouais pour pouvoir prendre des
décisions en notre âme et conscience on
c'est c'est surtout c'est en fait une
forme c'est de contrepouvoir alors
définition de contrepouvoir peut être
vaste en tout cas on est là pour faire
parler ceux qui veulent pas nous parler
on est là pour faire raconter des
histoires le reste c'est de la
communication et et et on est là pour
insister quand on a créé cash
investigation c'est de qui cette phrase
là le reste c'est de la communication
c'est eu Orwell je pense c'est ça il
faut checker je crois que c'est ça le
reste n'est que la communication euh
quand on a créé cash investigation avec
S attention expliquéou Paris je peux me
tromper mais mais quand on a créé cache
investigation c'était hyper intéressant
parce que on était dans un modèle
d'investigation je parle pour la télé
euh euh où euh
on avait à chaque fois cette phrase ce
commentaire pour dire il n'a pas voulu
nous parler cette entreprise a fermé sa
porte et tu avais le plan de la porte
qui se fermait ou tu avais le
communicant qui disait au téléphone non
désolé on vous parler pas et ça se
terminait comme ça et c'était un peu ça
et donc avec Élise et Jean-Pierre on a
voulu casser ça et on s'est dit non en
fait c'est pas parce qu'ils disent non
qu'on doit pas insister et donc l'idée
c'est qu'on allait insister et on allait
même pas seulement insister on allait
raconter qu'on allait insister et
montrer qu'on insistait parce que ça
allait faire aussi un effet neig montré
les premières enquêtes de de de cash et
on s'est dit en plus un autre truc on
s'est dit on va pas seulement faire des
sujets de 10 minutes mais des sujet de 2
heures quand on va faire l'évasion
fiscale on va pas aller faire le
dentiste qui traverse la montagne en
Suisse parce que il cache 10000 € ça n'a
aucun imp plus quand même
mais non par contre on va aller sur
Arcel ormital on va aller sur Price
Cooper on va aller sur Dour le Crédit
Mutuel avec Jean-Pierre Canet et Nicolas
veskovci qui ont qui ont quand même
beaucoup souffert et trinqué là-dessus
donc et ça c'était pour Canal Plus
connais le nom de code des lis du C et
qui a été diffusé sur le service public
non dis-moi non je te dirai pas si tu
lui demanderas ok je demand
mais j'ai perdu le le film mais quand
voilà just exprè ok [__] la technique
quand on a créé cash le but c'était de
dire on va en fait on va pas s'arrêter
au mail et on va pas prendre en otage
non plus un chef d'entreprise par contre
moi les chef ce que j'avais au début
donc ils étaient moi j'étais cofondateur
et j'étais donc et chef de la première
et 2uxè année et Elise Lucé avait à ce
moment-là présenté le trésor elle avait
présenté pièce à conviction avant donc
elle était quand même un peu connue dans
l'investigation mais elle présentait le
trésor donc les gens disaient plutôt il
y avait une partie des gens qui disaient
ah ouais une intervieu avec c'est super
et là il y avait un effet de surprise
qui se cool qui était énorme à voir où
les gens comprenaient qu'en fait c'était
une autre Élise Lucé qui arrivé avec un
dossier où il y avait une équipe de 15
personnes derrière qui avit bossé
pendant 6 mois tu parles de de Kiss
coool et et là il y av le
lapin et donc donc il y avait un effet
comme ça et puis après il y avait une
autre partie la deuxième partie des gens
qui disaient non monsieur Richard merci
mais c'est pas prévu dans le plan de
communication donc on fera pas
l'interview c'est pas encore leur
stratégie ouais mais ça ça m' arrivé
plein de fois et donc là c'est très
important de parler de ces séquences là
de conversation dans le livre informé
des pas qu'on a écrit à 16 j'ai fait un
chapitre qui s s'appelle le mur des
communiquants et ça c'est c'est je veux
bien qu'on s'arrête 5 minutes là-dessus
parce que c'est notre je t'autorise ok
mais c'est euh donc les gens disaient
non c'est pas prévu au plan de
communication donc il y aura pas
d'interview merci au revoir mais mais
peut-être plus tard donc en fait il y
avait déjà un rapport de force qui était
installé où je pense que pas mal
d'entreprises avaient aussi l'habitude
de travailler avec des journalistes où
plus reportage plus reportage ou quand
on travaille dans un service spécialisé
on on on peut dépendre un peu de ces
sourcesl euh et là ça peut créer c'est
pour ça que se spécialiser quand on est
journaliste moi en général quand
j'interviens on éc journaliste je vous
spécialiseer pas trop parce qu'après
vous allez dépendre des mêmes sources
vous allez travailler pour un seul
service et vous allez et vous allez
dépendre d'un planning de communication
de notre donc attention à ça en même
temps faut travailler avec ses sources
aussi donc il faut donc c'est c'est
complexe mais la réponse cétait ça donc
moi je leur disais ben en fait non on va
insister euh et puis surtout il y a un
truc auquel vous devez penser c'est que
vous
vendez vous vendez des médicaments vous
vendez des cigarettes vous vendez des
voitures vous vendez de la finance des
comptes en banque mais nos
téléspectateurs c'est aussi vos client
en fait donc pensez-y ne voyez pas ça
comme un truc complètement
clivé on se parle on fait ça pour le
service public il va y avoir des
millions de personnes qui vont regarder
et dedans il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
vos clients et Cash aussi ce qui était
important dans la création de cash pour
moi qui était essentiel c'était que en
arrivait après la crise financière après
la crise financière il s'est passé un
truc en 2008 où toutes les banques mais
toutes les entreprises dans le monde ont
communiqué de la même façon votre banque
vous doit des comptes on vous doit des
comptes et partout tout le temps sur les
C de bus partout c'était la transparence
afficher tout entreprises il y avait
j'aime ma banque ouais c'était ouais
c'était et après c'est devenu j'aime ma
banque peut-être mais d'abord c'était on
vous doit des comptes il y avait une
telle crise de défiance le monde
s'écroulé financièrement que toutes les
publicitaires sont dit attends on va
dire qu'on vous des comptes moi au
téléphone je disais mais vous devez des
comptes là par contre mais
maintenant et et en fait et on est en
train en exercice parce qu'on fait du
journalisme et on le fait pas pour nous
c'est pas pour informer les CIN
personnes dans maredac c'est pour parler
à des millions de personnes et c'est un
sujet d'intérêt général parce que
j'avais fait un sujet par exemple sur le
syndrome de la Ben et Sanofi
l'entreprise SAN pas une petite le le le
Graal de l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'était de trouver un médicament pour
faire perdre du poids pas du poids pour
faire pas de la beden ils avaient
calculé que le truc qui rongeait les
mecs de 40 à 60 ans c'était en se
regardant dans la glace le matin se dire
ah j'ai une beden mais ça trans femme ça
c'est toujours la faute de la femme de
toutes les façons le but c'était de
transformer cette beden en pathologie et
si on la transforma en pathologie il y
avait donc un médicament à ventre et
donc ça faisait faisait partie de ces
pathologies comme l'ostéoporose aussi où
il y a un énorme débat où on a
cholestérol ouais cholestérol ou le
précholestérol on a aussi les invité les
PR inventé les prémaladies le prédiabète
le précholestérol et tout ça donc j'ai
enquêté sur l'ostéoporose j'ai enquêté
sur le syndrome de la Ben et un truc
intéressant sur le syndrome de la ben
c'est que par rapport au communicant par
rapport à l'effet qui se coule et tout
ça et tout se
rejoint c'est que donc il y avait sof
voulait vendre une vendre un médicament
et pour vendre le médicament fallait
d'abord vendre une maladie et le doc
s'appelait maladie à ventre et et donc
il s'était dit en fait la beden c'est un
bon truc parce que ça touche énormément
et là on a un marché énorme et euh et du
coup le discours était de dire en fait
la graisse abdominale pourquoi la ben
serait une pathologie pas juste un exès
de graisse ils sont allés trouver des
chercheurs que je suis allé revoir à
Toronto et qui étaient bourré de conflit
d'intérêt et et qui ont dit de conflit
d'intérêt c'estd que en fait ça arrive
beaucoup dans la médecine pas tous les
médecins pas tous les chercheurs sont
comme ça encore une fois mais ça arrive
ça arrose grassement quand même l'étude
est financée par une industrie qui a un
projet spécifique et du coup il y a des
orientations scientifiques qui sont fait
et on souffre de
ça mais donc du coup il fallait il
disait le discours était de dire en fait
la graisse abdominale est plus
dangereuse que les autres graisses et il
faut lutter contre ça et du coup o ils
ont créé un site le
syndromeedelabuden.com ou.org et ils ont
trouvé il fallait trouver quelqu'un pour
vendre ça un commercial ils ont trouvé
un gars qui s'appelait Boris Ansel et
qui était médecin chef de service à la
Pitié Salpétrière donc c'est c'est des
noms c'est des noms connus ça
et il a fait un site qui s'appelleit s
de la ben un livre qui s'appelleait s de
la buden et et il a vendu son livre on a
découvert après coup que en fait il
avait c'était Sanofi qui avait acheté
5000 premiers
exemplaires mais
Élise Luc dans quand elle était
présentatrice de trésor l'avait reçu en
tant qu'invité et avait il y avait une
série produite par l'équipe éditoriale
du JT de 13or de France 2 sur le
syndrome de la Boden cette pathologie
qui est inquiétante et réussi à ouais et
en enquétant dessus je découvre que
Élise a reçu ce chercheur-là et donc je
vais voir éélise et je lui dis écoute
j'enquête sur C de la ben pour au fille
euh mais le gars est venu sur ton
plateau et France 2 a fait un sujet sur
plusieurs sujets sur de la beden et tu
as fait la promo enfin il a fait la
promotion de son livre et tout et
elle a dit mais super donc on le raconte
et on le fait et du coup on est allé est
trop chou pour ça on est allé voir mais
elle est géniale et on est allé voir
franchement petite parenthèse sur ise sa
euh il y en a il y en a pas deux comme
elle c'est que elle présentait le trésor
euh allait risquer sa réputation en
poursuivant des des chefs d'entreprise
des grands chercheurs comme ça et tout
péchu elle respecte toujours sa parole
ouais elle y va et c'est et je la et
c'est une très bonne amie personnelle et
elle est elle est voilà c'est quelqu'un
de solide et donc on est allé voir Boris
enelle
ensemble à la pité Sal pétrière et on a
fait une interview et il a dit
bonjour Par qu' il était content de
revoirise et moi j'avais donné toutes
les infos à ise Lucé j'étais allé à
Toronto avant faire le chercheur P voir
établir les conflits d'intérêt j'avais
interviewé les gens de la revue
Prescrire qui était une super revue de
chercheurs indépendants et qui disait
attention c'est très dangereux et
d'ailleurs au passage pardon le Sanofi
avait mis en place sur le marché par mis
sur le marché un médicament qui
s'appelait le rimonaban et qui avait tué
des dizaines de personnes ça a duré 6
mois il a été retiré parce que il
voulait soigner le C de la Boden ils ont
tué des gens et donc ça a été retiré le
médicament était été jugé trop dangereux
et donc on est allé voir le celui qui
avait vendu le cend de la ben pour la
part pour la France et et Lise l'a
interviewé et donc il y a une partie de
l'interview qu'on appelle entre nous
laapéro je sais pas si toi tu as la même
le même les mêmes noms de code mais qui
une façon qui est assez poli aussi de de
se parler et pu des préliminaires voilà
c'est je sais pas si on est dans une
amoureuse mais mais et puis et puis
elise a sorti les éléments les éléments
de notre enquête pour dire en fait c'est
compliqué parce que le syndr de la beden
c'est un s'est contesté de médicament a
fait du mal euh TR on s'est rendu compte
que les livres avaient été achetés par
votre maison d'édition 4 que vous aviez
des conflits d'intérêt 5 comment vous
réagissez à ça et donc et donc ça
c'était la première année de cash et je
crois que c'était le premier numéro de
ch et je j'étais chef et je le réaliser
aussi ce je coréalisé cette enquête là
et vendr Lanos donc c 5 minutes sont
épuisé c'était quoi la première question
de de ta question à toi c'était c'était
c'était un truc sur la caste des
journalistes et des ménages non c ça je
sais plus donc les ménages c'est ça
ouais les ménages euh bah il y en a des
ménages les ménages moi je je pense que
c'est une catastrophe absolue d'enfire
euh c'est que et d'ailleurs c'est ENF je
sais pas quelle est la loi exacte
là-dessus les chartes disent en gros
quand tu es al tu as plusieurs chartes
tu as la charte de Munich tu as la
charte
du la charte charte du SNJ je crois et
une charte européenne je crois mais il y
a la charte de Munich qui est vraiment
la base de des chartes qui datent de de
1971 les basiques c'est été d'ailleurs
révé très récemment euh oui avec en gros
des droits et des devoirs pardon je un
peu mais voilà qui dit en gros un
journaliste digne de ce nom ne confond
pas son métier euh avec avec le métier
de communicquant et et d'auxiliaire de
police de
justice sur et juste sur les ouais donc
sur les je sais où on en était on était
sur les les communiquants aussi
euh je sais plusù du tout o on était
pardon on fait une diversion quand tu es
allé voir Macron pour lui dire écoute
Macron tu es bien gentil mais tu as un
Pegasus sur ton téléphone et d'ailleurs
ta ministre de la Défense elle s'est
fait poutrer comme toi prer ça veut dire
tu t'es fait en foncé avec on l' pas dit
dans ces mots là non compr pas ce même
langage non je suis s
comprend non non c'est l'équipe du monde
qui a averti Emmanuel
Macron en physique ou genre non par
message sur le téléphone en question
magnifique donc je crois que c'est c'est
soit martininger ou Damien le loup du
mononde très bien Martin ou qui depuis
le bureau du monde
on a fait un doc sur Pegasus et jeis
qu'on a fil ce momentlà qu' on voit un
message à un moment donné on donc on
enquête pendant longtemps euh et puis
vient le moment où il est du
contradictoire c'est-à-dire on va voir
les personnes sur lesquelles on enquête
donc on va voir NSO on va voir l'Arabie
Saoudite enfin on essaie d'aller voir on
envoie des mail on essaie de de
rencontrer les gens on va voir les
victimes beaucoup de victimes on on fait
certaines victimes acceptent de nous
prêter leur téléphone et Amnesy sécurité
là nos partenaires qui sont juste
géniaux et j'aimerais bien dire des mots
sur eux parce que que ils ont fait un
travail en terme de société civile mais
qui a qui pour moi change le monde peut
peut le changer amnesti security Lab a
trouvé des traces d'infection c'estàd
que non seulement on avait nous cette
liste où il y avait des numéros de
téléphone de potentielle infection mais
c'était pas ça disait pas tout c'était
pas une preuve formelle et après il y
avait les gens d'amnestie sécité qui
disaient non on est rentré dans le
téléphone on a trouvé des traces
d'exloit ça s'est activé à cette
heure-là ce jour-là et du coup on avait
du contexte pour savoir en fait
qu'est-ce qui était disait pourquoi
pourquoi cette cible était ciblée ce
jour-là à cette secondelà parce que il
avait un entretien avec telle personne
parce que c'était
du plinel il a été visé par Pegasus
c'était à l'occasion d'un déplacement au
Maroc je crois esawira où il faisait une
conférence sur pour bousculer un peu le
régime marocain donc à un moment donné
il fait ça isawira je crois que c'était
isawira je crois qu'il étaé invité par
les ouais c'est très beau par les gens
de the desk qui sont qui est un journal
qui indépendant qui travaille dur là-bas
pour malgré les pressions et pour
revenir à Emmanuel Macron donc c'est
l'équipe du monde qui le prévient et
donc il envoie un message sur le
téléphone
visé d'ailleurs au passage très
compliqué cette enquête parce que
comment communiquer avec des gens qui
sont surveillés euh parce que c'est très
risqué donc on et pendant le covid où on
peut pas trop voyager donc je pour
raconter plus tard un peu comment on a
fait mais donc il envoie un message à
Emmanuel Macron et là 15 minutes après
non je crois que c'est le chef du
service politique du monde qui reçoit un
message de quelqu'un de l'Élysée pas de
Macron qui dit qu'est-ce qui se passe
parce que le président là a reçu un
message qui l'inquiète vraiment ben vous
êtes desbel voilà ce qui se passe et et
d'ailleurs pour info on peut retrouver
sur cet été en juillet Libé a fait une
longue enquête sur ce moment-là le
moment où Macron a appris en
interrogeant les collaborateurs de
Macron comment il était quand il a
appris qu'il était visé par Pégasus et
beaucoup disent on l'a jamais vu comme
ça il était blê et il a dit ce roi est
en voyou ce est un voyou ce roi est un
voyou en parlant du roi du Maroc donc
c'est ça c'est la la journaliste de Libé
qui a fait un papier qui qui documentait
entre autres ce moment-là mais donc
l'équipe du monde a reçu un message ça a
été prouvé que c'était le roi ouais ça a
été en fait ce qu'a fait amnest ton coup
là ce qu'a fait Amnesty security Lab
c'est qu'ils ont analysé un grand nombre
de journal un grand nombre de téléphones
qui appartenaient à des journalistes
marocains dissidant en France de
journalistes ocain au Maroc au Marad par
exemple qui est un journaliste qui a été
libéré cet été après 6 ans passés en
prison et qui était un journaliste dont
on avait révélé effectivement qu'il
avait été infecté par Pegasus et les
traces qu'ils ont trouvé sur toutes les
ciblebl Marocaines avait des vecteurs
communs des portes d'entrée commune et
qui dessinent un pattern d'infection
schéma un schéma d'infection propre à ce
compte client là oui mais qui dit que
c'était le roi derrière ah ça ça ça dit
en tout cas qu'il y a que tous ces
profils là euh
euh marocains euh sont ciblés de la même
façon techniquement euh par ce même
compte client- là et on sait si approuve
rien par rapport au roi ça peut être ça
oui oui ça peut c'est c'est pas non
c'est pas le roi pardon qui est derrière
la console elle-même mais c'est aussi on
sait qu'il y a une tradition du
renseignement très forte au sein des
services de renseignement marocain
encore he mais je te rassure avant
c'était pareil chez nous ouais mais il y
a plein d'autres pays le projet Pegasus
cétait on s'est intéressé à à plein de
pays et donc juste pour revenir sur
Emmanuel
Macron en
fait on lui a demandé on savait que ça
alla non s'il était ok pour nous passer
son téléphone pour faire des ét quand
même mer mais évidemment c'était un nom
et lany nous a dit on va le faire
nous-même euh et il y a eu aucune ça
c'est en 2021 on est en 2024 et à ce
jour on ne sait toujours pas quel est le
résultat de l'analyse du téléphone
d'Emmanuel Macron qui t' passé pour des
cons vaut mieux pas le donner au
journalistes parce que sinon on passe
deux fois plus pour des cons ouais mais
c'est c'est pas une question si légère
que ça ou si Dr que ça c'est que on a un
chef de l'État qui utilise des produits
pas sécurisés ouais absolument et on lui
a donné le feu nuclére quand même c'est
quand même dramatique voilà donc on est
à ce autant c'est la faute du chef de
l'État ou c'est la faute des gens qui
surveille le chef de du moins pas qui
surveille qui sont censés protéger le
chef de l'État estce que un jour ou
l'autre il va falloir que qu' a
quelqu'un qui assume en France
c'està-dire les services censés protéger
notre chef de l'État sont-ils des burnes
non ils sont pas ou le président de la
République est incontrôlable il écoute
pas les recommandations je je option 2
je pense euh je pense que de ce qu'on a
eu en off par différentes personnes
proches de lui c'est que en fait on N a
dit mais il y a un protocole très simple
il y a trois types de téléphon à sa
disposition un qui est ultra chiffré un
autre qui est entre les deux et le sien
perso et euh et nos journalistes qui ont
questionné cette source là j' ont dit ok
qu'est-ce que vous dites au président ah
ben c'est le Président c'est lui qui
décide ça c'est dramatique c'est le
problème c'est que on na pas laissé
enfin c'est que si on dirige l'État et
qu'on a des conversations alors après
moi je sais pas je ne sais pas s'il a
été infecté réellement son téléphone
parce qu'il y a pas de transparence ça
c'est un vrai sujet le fait qu'il y a
pas de transparence ça c'est un vrai
problème parce que c'est la sûreté de
l'État qui est en jeu media part a
réussi à révéler parce qu' a réussi à à
à à révéler que cinq ministres avait été
réellement infecté dont euh don je sais
je sais plus lesquels mais je pense
défense solidarité on s'en fout mais le
ministre de la Défense oui je ministre
de la Défense et il y avait il y en
avait 4ut mais là je veux pas dire de
bêtises je sais je sais plus et on pour
regarder ça mais il y a
la c'était mediaap qui a en tout cas
publié euh sans doute en en août ou
septembre 21 cette info là mais le fait
de pas savoir en fait Pegasus ce qu' il
y a plusieurs choses intéressante c'est
que un
euh c'est des journalistes qui ont
informé un appareil d'État de qu'ils
étaient ciblés c'est un premier problème
c'était normalement ça ça veut dire le
chef de l'État ne fait pas audité
régulièrement son téléphone personnel
ouais ou il je sais pas en tout cas il y
a des services comme LAN qui sont qui
travaillent dessus ça veut dire qu' son
pass bonjour à monsieur
paayou qui ça paou c'est paou qui est
Len qui c'est qui est déjà Len non l
c'était Poupard Poupard pardon monsieur
Poupard euhou est mieux ouais ouais mais
le bon sa charge est énorme Jean-Michel
blanqueur Jacqueline gourau Julie de
Normandie
manuel vargon Julien de Normandie ouais
Sébastien le Cornu ainsi qu'un diplomate
ouais
donc ça c'est ce qui a été mais ça c'est
ce qui a été révélé par une fuite à
médiap mais il y avit pas eu d'effort de
transparence de l'État il y a pas eu il
y a une seule communication d'ailleurs
nos amis du monde on fait un l'ont
marqué sur un meug qui nous ont offert
si les faits sont avérés ils sont donc
très graves c'était ça la ligne de
communication post révélation de
Pegasus alors après derrière il y a eu
une des convocations du ministre d'un
ministre israélien par le ministre de la
Défense la ministre de défense française
une petite tap pète sur la fesse non on
lui a dit la France a dit a pris une
position parce que Pegasus ce logiciel
là les États-Unis avaient obtenu que les
citoyens américains les plus 1 donc les
citoyens qui utilisent un numéro plus 1
américain soit épargné ne soit pas
infectable et quand la France a su que
les États-Unis avait un plus 100 qui av
été mis sur la liste VIP en gros des
intouchables euh de ce que l'on a pu
lire dans la presse donc c'est
je le sais pas de source directe mais la
mise à défense a demandé à ce que les +
33 soient aussi exclus euh du du système
Pegasus en disant c'est scandaleux tout
notre gouvernement apparemment est sur
cette liste donc on veut plus que les+
33 so et ils auraient obtenu gain de
cause mais il a ils auraient ils
auraient parce queil y a pas de
commission d'enquête parlementaire en
fait il y a la question de l'exécutif et
après il y a les question des
parlementaires est-ce qu'il s'en
emparent ou pas mais ça aurait été pour
pour les sujets de cyber surveillance et
c'est le drame on peut en parler il y a
aucun contrôle ouais mais il pourrait
ben je sais pas il y a d'autres pays où
il y a où ça travaille un peu en
commission d'enquête parlementaire il
pourrait il y a une commission d'enquête
parlementaire d'ailleurs qui a fait un
travail remarquable au niveau européen
vraiment et qui a auditionné le
vice-président de NSO aussi qui était
l'une des rares paroles publiques tenu
par NSO qui a permis d'apprendre
différents éléments qui étaient
intéressants et qui a auditionné des
victimes qui a auditionné et qui a
débouché sur des conclusions qui sont
absolument pas suivi par personne à la
fin mais au moins au moins il y a eu un
espace de questionnement et certains
parlementaires avaient vraiment bossé
leur d'accord toi tu es journaliste tu
es bon tu es gentil tu as le grand cœur
et quand tu dis au moins ça a
servi non non mais je suis pas je suis
pas B et optimiste du tout ah quand même
ah non pas du tout non non non non j'ai
pas fini non ce que je disais tout à
l'heure que je commençais par ça c'est
que c'est toi qui me disais non on peut
qu même se protéger de ça je pense qu'on
peut pas se protéger de ça mais tu sais
comment on se protège en ouais en se
baladant tout dans une forêt et en ne se
connectant jamais à une pr é c'est toi
qui te balade tout dans la c'est pas moi
il dire qu'on est du M village c'est
pour ça ouais voilà non il faut aussi
publier des enquêtes des des activistes
veulent faire leur manifestation des
dissidents veulent communiquer pour
dénoncer un cas de corruption en
Azerbaïdjan voilà le nous on travaille
au contact avec des journalistes azée
qui travaillent pour ABS une partie
d'entre eux est parti en prison fin
novembre dernier et l'Azerbaïdjan
utilise ce type de logiciel là donc
citoyen en tant que citoyen quand tu
vois tu es patriote
ou là j'ai pas dit tu es nationaliste
j'ai dit est-ce que tu es patriote mais
ça veut dire quoi patriote est-ce que
quand on touche à la France tu défendras
la France be non moi je suis journaliste
très bien je suis journaliste donc je je
suis journaliste je enfin on parle de
mon métier là je suis là en tant que
forbidden story journist pourquoi je te
pose la question
euh pour savoir si si au nom de
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation j'irait
ne pas donner uneinformation la réponse
est non jamais un vrai journaliste bah
je sais je sais ah non mais il faut pas
qu'on soit dans le sketch des Inconnus
avec les chasseurs les bons et les
mauvais chasseurs c'est rien de pire et
ça fait pas avancer le débat sincèrement
alors la Galinette
sandR non mais ben
non il y avait quand on a les Pegasus
les les autorités nous ont dit ah vous
avez une liste de 50000 personnes bah
donnez la nous et nous on a dit non et
là ils nous ont dit bah attendez vous
êtes de quel côté vous voulez protéger
les victimes nous on peut les informer
et nous on a dit mais non en fait nous
on est journaliste on révèle
l'information d'ailleurs finalement on
on a révélé des des informations sur les
victimes que parce qu'elles avaient un
un un profil de personnalité publique et
au nom de l'intérêt général c'était un
journaliste commeedwi plinel qui était
visé c'était très important de le rendre
public
ou un membre d'un gouvernement ou un
journaliste un journaliste au Mexique
Cecilio Peneda qui était mort et on a
retrouver son
téléphone le numéro de ses téléphone
dans la liste donc on n pas pu faire
d'analyse forensique parce que le
téléphone avait été est toujours sous
Cellé en fait dans un commissariat mais
on a vraiment essayé de le retrouver
mais c'est SIO qui était l'un des
premiers sujets de on stories on a
poursuit son enquête euh je vous Ron le
juste un truc sur Pegasus pour raconter
le profil et à quoi ça sert euh par dans
nos révélations on a révélé que vous
rappelez de Jamal kashugi qui a été
démembré donc journaliste saoudien qui
travailler pour qui était éditorialiste
au Washington Post et qui était l'une
des rares voix dissidentes sur le régime
d'Arabie Saoudite qu'il a pas tout le
temps critiqué mais qu'il a aussi
beaucoup critiqué
euh il a été c'est un jour il se rend
dans au consulat d'Arabie Saoudite du
Royaume d'Arabie Saoudite en Turquie
pour sonorisé ouais qui était totalement
sonorisé l'histoire le montrera plus
tard il y va en fait pour des questions
de papier et de mariage et il est
attendu il y va pas seul il y va avec
Atié qui est sa fiancée et qui lui dit
mais je t'attends devant et elle attend
devant l'entrée et il y a des caméras
vidéurveillance où on voit Jamal qui
rentre a Tich qui lui dit au revoir et
elle attend devant et Jama il ressort
pas et puis a Tich elle s'inquiète si il
est ressorti
ouais mais il est ressorti il est en
fait il est ils
l'ont ils l'ont convoqué il est rentré
dans une pièce il a vu des mecs se
rapprocher ils l'ont ils lui ont dit non
vous me ramenez pas en Arabie Saoudite
ils ont dit tranquillise-toi ils l'ont
pris de force ils l'ont injecté un
produit ils l'ont endormi et ensuite ils
l'ont tué et ensuite ils l'ont découpé
ce qui qui l'ont découpé écouté de la
musique dans des casques pour ne pas
entendre le bruit de la S circulaire
qu'ils utilisaient et ceux qui l'ont
découpé étit envoyé par le roi d'Arabie
Saoudite dans des avions affrités par
l'Arabie Saoudite qui s'étaiit déposé
sur le tarmac et après sont repartis
après l'opération ils ont fait croire
que Jamal kashugi était ressorti en
utilisant un gars qu'ils avaient
embauché comme Souzi de Jamal kashogi en
remettant les affaires de Jamal ils
l'ont ils l'ont déshabillé pour le
découper et ils ont redonné les affaires
de Jamal à ce garslà ce saoudien pour
qu'il soit pour soit vu par les caméras
de vidéosurveillance se baler dans des
parcs et tout ça et et puis l'enquête
montrera que c'était pas Jamal et que
c'était quelqu'un qui portait les
affaires de Jamal que c'était un leur
pendant ce temps-là Tich elle attend
elle a pas de nouvelles mais il y a un
truc qui se passe sur son téléphone
c'est qu'elle est infectée par Pegasus
et ça on a découvert ça parce qu'on a on
ne sait pas si Jamal lui-même était
infecté il y a des rumeurs il y a eu
voilà c'était dit on sait pas on n pas
eu accès à son téléphone on a pas fait
d'analyse on sait que par contre les
personnes à qui parlait très souvent
était infecté don a tiché sa phase sa
fiancée et aussi j'ai oublié son prénom
une autre Jamal avait une VI compliquée
il avait à la fois une épouse et une
fiancée et j'ai oublié Annan nalatar qui
vivait à Washington
ou je sais plus viv était aussi infecté
mais en gros mais ça c'est souvent une
bonne façon de surveiller les gens en
laissant le moins de traces possible
c'est d'infacter l'entourage et pas
directement la personne parce que la
personne est une personnalité publique
sensible et qu'immédiatement après son
assassinat à son enlèvement il y aura
des analyses de faites par une force qui
enquête dessus et nous on a découvert on
est allé voir à Tich donc c'est la
journaliste du Washington Post qui
travaille avec nous d' pris qui était la
voir et qui a dit à Titch est-ce que
c'est possible de nous passer votre
téléphone et pendant tout le projet
Pegasus on est allé voir des gens pour
dire est-ce que vous nous passez votre
téléphone on 50 ou 80 journalistes on va
rien voir de du contenu de Vau messages
mais par contre on va confier ça à amnes
security Lab qui va voir s'il y a des
traces d'infection et on a trouvé des
traces infections jourg à leure hache où
elle attendait Jamal et en fait le
Royaume d'Arabie Saoudite voulait
maîtriser et savoir ce que sa fiancée
allait dire allait savoir du meurtre
voulait maîtriser totalement le narratif
de la disparition de de Jamal kashugi et
donc on a fait ça avec en faisant
l'analyse forencique du téléphone
portable de de de de la fiancée de Jamal
on est allé voir Khadija ismaillova
journaliste en Azerbaïdjan on a profité
d'un déplacement qu'elle faisait pour
des raisons de santé en Turquie pour lui
dire est-ce que tu es sur on voit ton
téléphone sur la liste et on aimerait si
tu en es d'accord procéder à des
analyses Claudio carieri
de était en Allemagne a fait l'analyse à
distance il a dit tu es surinecté et et
c'est je parle de cadij un instant parce
que c'est une amie et et c'est une
personne qui est une journiste en
Azerbaïdjan très courageuse qui a été
surveillée de deux façons différentes
une fois de manière traditionnelle et
ancienne en 2012 et une autre fois par
Pegasus traditionnelle ancienne
c'estàdire au callback dans la rue suivi
dans la rue ouais ça mais plus version
un peu upgradée ils avaient mis des
caméras de vidéosurveillance partout
dans dans son appartement qui était pas
immense qui était de trois pièces y
compris dans ses toilettes et dans son
salon et dans sa chambre à coucher et ça
c en 2012 et en 2020 c'est dates
d'infection de Khadija elle est elle est
infectée par Pegasus c'est hyper
intéressant parce que elle a un regard
sur ce ces deux modes de surveillance là
et ça raconte un peu de la menace de la
cybersurveillance sur le journalisme et
sur l'accès à l'information et à quel
point on vit une époque qui est grave et
pour laquelle et contre un un pour
lequel on peut pas se défendre je finis
juste sur Khadija Kadija dit en 2012
cétait des caméras de vidéosurveillance
c'était l'horreur mais la victime
c'était moi et quand d'ailleurs quand
elle a un jour elle a sous sa porte
comment elle a appris qu'elle était
surveillée sous sa porte elle a ouvert
une enveloppe et dans l'enveloppe il y
avait des screenshots des captures
d'écran d'elle avec son
compagnon ils étaient nus il faisaient
l'amour et il y avait un mot qui disait
si tu compes continue son enquête on
publie ça et cadjja c'est une femme
merveilleuse courageuse qui a fait un
truc que peu d'entre nous oserait faire
elle a publié elle-même non elle a elle
a organisé une conférence de presse pour
dire vous allez voir ces image là mais
c'est pour cette enquête là et donc elle
a assuré un certain écho à à son enquête
qu'elle menait à l'époque sur la
corruption du régime aliief qui est donc
le nom du président qui dirige ce
pays-là
et elle a et évidemment les vidéos sont
sorties et et ça lui a causé beaucoup de
tort parce que son intimité a été
totalement violée donc ça était un
traumatisme énorme pour elle mais elle
dit Pegasus c'est bien pire parce que en
2012 cette caméra la victime c'était moi
et mon compagnon avec Pegasus en fait
Pegasus c'est radioactif toutes les
personnes qui m'ont fait confiance en
jour et qui m'ont appelé en fait elles
sont dedans et ça victimise en fait tout
le monde en fait ça attaque tout le
monde c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
intéressant le terme d'infection qui est
pas un terme inventé par ceux qui
enquête dessus c'est l'industrie qui
parle d'infection mais c'est comme
quelque chose d' qui de manière
organique va se dissiminer dans votre
entourage et non seulement ça capte ce
que les personnes vous disent et donc
Kadija elle se disait des avocats des
sources ma famille des gens qui m'ont
fait confiance m'ont confier leur secret
je dois aller leur dire maintenant que
en fait au moment où ils m'ont parlé
j'étais je viens de comprendre que
j'étais infecté par Pegasus et que ils
sont sans doute eux-mêmes surveillés du
coup ou sans doute ces informations là
sont su par une autorité qui vous veut
du mal ou va vous vouloir du mal un jour
et donc elle dit voilà c'est radioactif
donc c'est ça c'est très intéressant
parce que ça raconte à 8 ans d'écart
comment la surveillance a évolué à quel
point on peut rien vraiment contre ça
sauf à utiliser peut-être des outils un
peu plus safe que d'autres en faisant
attention en mettant des couches
par-dessus des couches et en sachant
surtout ce qu'on veut protéger pour
revenir à ce que je disais au départ
qu'est-ce qu'on protège la vie de la
source qui la vie de la personne qui
vous parle on pourra pas tout protéger
tu toxique jamais ceux qui te
surveillent C pardon j'ai pas compris la
question tuin toxique jamais ceux qui te
surveill ouais la le
ouais j'avais des copains qui faisaient
ça qui donnai des pour voir s'ils
étaient surveillés avait des
conversations pour dire mais on se voit
on se voit à cette heurel dans ce café
là et je te donnerai l'info et pour voir
s'il y avait du monde qui venait ou pas
jamais fait ça
euh non juste un détail ouis on prend un
qu de figure on intoxique les gens qui
nous surveillent on leur fit le encart
dans une
forêt que tu connais bien et dans cette
forêt tu sais que il y a jamais de
voiture là parce que tu es dans la forêt
souvent et que tu connais très bien ton
village par cœur tu tombes sur un gars
et tu découvres qui te surveille tu lui
fais fais quoi tu dis
bon passe ta route tu le sors de sa
caisse et tu lui éclates la gueule non
tuas jamais eu envie non franchement tu
es pacifiste en plus mais non je suis
pas c'est pas ça c'est que je suis pas
je suis pas débile je suis pas
je je suis surtout pas débile et je vais
pas je vais pas faire quelque chose qui
me sera reproché je vais-ce que moi
franchement ma réponse et ça fait ça
fait ça fait promo forbidon stories mais
en même temps je je pas venu rien ouais
je suis pas venu pour rien et puis je
suis content de le faire c'est que il
faut qu'on travaille ensemble en fait à
plusieurs on est plus fort tu travailles
avec des hackurs ouais absolument on va
travailler c'est que c'est des hackurs
qui qui nous donnent des informations je
peux je peux donner un exemple hyper
intéressant qui raconte que qui puisse
pas remonter jusqu'au cur bien sûr non
non mais en remontant jusqu'auur mais
avec son accord et avec son pseudonyme
euh
guakamaya c'est un collectif euh c'est
en
fait pendant qu'on était en train de
faire le projet Pegasus j'ai j'étais en
contact avec un collectif de hackur qui
qui est connu qui qui se fait appeler
guakamaya et qui je discutais depuis
quelques temps avec eux quelques années
et et j'étais épuisé par le projet
Pegasus qu'on avait pas encore sorti et
j'étais limite en burnout et j'étais
parti euh euh dans les Alpes euh j'étais
épuisé et euh et guakamaya m'a dit j'ai
un cadeau pour toi euh est-ce que tu es
prêt à recevoir euh 4 TER euh et je
alors oui mais de quoi sur quoi et tout
donc euh il m'a donné un endroit de
conversation que je donnerai pas là
euh et euh guakamaya
euh il est il est très intéressant comme
à cœur parce que il il hack et il filme
son hack et raconte son hack donc c'est
très dur pour l'entreprise hack parce
que il révèle la façon dont il l'a fait
et il filme ça donc il montre les lignes
de commande il montre sa stratégie tout
ça et tout il est très open source dans
la façon de hacké et en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que guakamaya avait ce
collectif là avait
hacké une entreprise sur laquelle on
avait précédemment enquêté euh en 2018
on a fait une un projet qui s'appelait
green blood le sang vert le point de
départ était le suivant il y a beaucoup
de journalistes qui meurent parce qu'ils
enquête sur des crimes environnementaux
et ça c'est hyper important parce que
c'est on avait fait un projet où on
poursuivait les enquêtes de trois
journalistes aucun des trois ne se
connaissait mais il travaillent tous sur
le même sujet sans le savoir jag and
rassing en Inde qui travaille sur le la
mafia du sable en gros des entreprises
qui minent illégalement le sable pour
ensuite l'exporter et le sable ça sert à
la construction à plein de plein de
ouais entre autres euh un journaliste en
Tanzanie qui était forcé à l'exil qui
était menacé parce qu'il enquêtait sur
une mine d'or qui revendait et après de
l'or dans la silicone valallleé et un
peu partout le sable de Ja and rassing
en Inde il finissait à Paris à New York
dans des boîtes qu'on a retrouvé et un
autre journaliste qui s'appelle Carlos
Chock qui est un journaliste de la
communauté mayakechi au Guatemala qui
vit au bord du lac Isabal je crois euh à
elestor et ce journaliste là un jour il
couvre une manifestation de pêcheurs qui
sont foudrage parce que le lac où il
pêche est devenu tout rouge et il y a
une tache rouge au milieu tout le
poisson est mort et la communauté vit du
poisson qui pêche donc ils peuvent plus
manger il proteste la police arrive et
tire à balle réel et tue l'un de ses
pêcheurs Carlos Chock il est photo
reporter il prend la photo de ce pêcheur
au sol et pour ça il est poursuivi il
est harcelé il est arrêté il est
emprisonné il vit dans la clandesité il
vit l'horreur absolue et il appartient à
une communauté Mayaki donc destor et ça
ses collègues en fait nous contactent
pour est-ce que vous pouvez faire
quelque chose poursivre le travail de
Carlos Schock ça vaudrait le coup il y a
vraiment quelque chose à faire d'autant
qu'il y a une mine qui opéré par une
entreise s'appelle CGN pronico qui est
la filiale de Solway qui est un géant
basé à la fois en Estonie je crois et en
Suisse et je crois c'est parce que je
parce que j'ai cru un que c'était russe
en fait c'est ça dépend de nationalité
du moiim pas les gens qui croient ouais
mais j'ai pas une mémoire tout le temps
parfaite et ça peut se retrouver on a
écrit là-dessus mais quand quand j'ai un
doute je le dis en tout cas en tout cas
le ciel social est en Suisse euh et et
en tout cas il mine il il il vend des
exporte et recueil du nickel et euh et
en fait on a raconté on a poursui le
travail de carlchoc on a interrogé la
mine notre consortium a envoyé des gens
du gardian du monde d'El païs des gens
de de de la communauté
mayakechi Prin sa comitaria qui sont
allés interroger les gens de la mine
mais aussi des magistrats qui étaient
corrompu en fait sur place et donc il y
avait tout un travail d'enquête et
on publie ça on publie toute l'enquête
et la l'entreprise solou nous mène un
procès d'ailleurs contre forbid stories
et contre le monde et puis donc quelques
2 ans plus tard je reçois ce message de
guakamaya qui me dit j'ai un cadeau pour
toi j'avais j'ai je me suis intéressé à
une entreprise à laquelle vous êtes
intéressé c'est l'entreprise CGN pronic
et j'ai 4 t sur eux et tu verras il y a
des trucs qui vous concernent ex forbid
stories c'est Noël et et donc on a
indexé toutes ces datas là ça prend un
peu de temps puis commencé à chercher et
en fait il y avait un folder un dossier
sécurité et dedans on a trouvé des
vidéos de nos propres équipes filmé à
leur insu par l'équipe de sécurité des
des gros bras de la mine en fait qui
suivait notre équipe avec des petites
caméras qui suivit notre équipe par
drone sur place et mais ça limite
c'était attendu après on a trouvé dans
le lic plein de trucs hyper intéressants
on a trouvé un SPRE un tableur Excel qui
disait comment voilà le plan pour
récupérer cette partie là de terre et
pour pouvoir exploiter le nickel il faut
plus qu'il y ait de gens qui vivent
dessus donc là une des solutions ils
l'ont pas fait mais une des solutions
c'était marqué dans le tableur option a
répondre des rumeurs de VIH sur cette
communauté pour qu'il soit forcé à
partir option de lancer des feux
d'incendie de manière dispersée comme ça
et option 3 je me rappelle plus et tout
c'est les conspirationnistes ouis ça
c'était c'était pas les
conspirationnistes c'était oui ah oui
une rumeur quis aurait pu balancer mais
en tout cas ça ça venait d'un service
d'une entreprise qui est un géant minier
et et donc évidemment on l'a révélé et
quand ils nous ont poursuivi en
diffamation évidemment j'ai fait état de
ces éléments devant le magistrat pour
dire l'entreprise et vous les avocat
français qui défendait cette
multinationale là c'est cette même
entreprise qui fait des tableur Excel
qui visent à répondre des maladies
c'est cette même entreprise dont où au
final le le journaliste se retrouve
forcé à l'exil parce qu'il a osé prendre
une photo et tout voilà à répondre des
rumeurs de maladie ouis ouais répondre
des rumeurs de maladie pardon
euh donc donc voilà donc tout ça pour
dire que guakamaya avait euh nous a
transmis en fait des éléments dessus et
qu'on a travaillé là-dessus donc ça
c'est euh c'est euh c'est une
effectivement un des cas où on a reçu
des informations fournies par par un
hackur question internet ouais
et que je résume très trivialement
après je la
récupère beaucoup de
questions est-ce queil y a
une neutralité journalistique
attendez
euh la neutralité c'est impossible
est-ce que tu trouves pas qu'il y a un
peu trop de militants politiques qui
sortent des écoles de journalisme et qui
terminent dans des des rédactions qui on
une couleur politique est-ce que pour
toi le journalisme devrait être
au-dessus de ce militantisme de
baseétage qui traînent dans les salles
de rédaction mais je sais je sa que ce
soit à droite à gauche ou centre ouais
mais je sais franchement je moi je je
généralise pas de cette façonlà en
disanti je généralise pas mais de mais
c'est une question qui est posée et donc
j'y réponds
euh moi je trouve que le le problème par
rapport au éc aux écoles de journalistme
pardon c'est pas celui-là c'est quoi
c'est que il reproduisent les mêmes
schémas oui il y a un souci en fait les
écoles de journ elles sont notées euh
sur une valeur qui est-ce que l'étudiant
a année à à à plus un an plus 2 ans a
trouver un travail ou pas mais ce qui en
soi fait sens on fait quand on si on
inscrire nos enfants dans une école de
journalisme et qu'on paye pour ça on a
plutôt envie qu'il trou je je je je je
sais pas sincèrement quels sont les
frais d'inscription mais ça peut être ça
dépend des écoles 7000 € par an ouais je
je je sais je sais pas mais sans doute
ouais mais le truc c'est que les
journalistes en fait moi c'est souvent
ce que je quand j'interviens en école
journalisme c'est souvent ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est tu rémunéré quand
tu vas intervenir en éc journalisme
ouais j'ai enseigné à Science Po c'est
60 € les TR par heure personne n'est
parfait personne non mais c'était j'ai
en fait j'ai proposé à Science Po
d'enseigner le journalisme collaboratif
justement pour C fabricer pboin euh oui
de de de non de réputation un peu ouais
quelle réputation il a
euh non je sais non je je sais pas de de
non en tout cas ouais de faire ton
journaliste là fais attention hein ouais
mais je sais pas tu là j'étais parti
pour te raconter quelque chose sur le
journalisme collaboratif et le le sujet
des écoles je je finis juste là-dessus
tu répondras à ma question quand même
hein ouais mais je j'ai rien à dire sur
Fabrice c'est et réputation c'est quoi
comme réputation non non pas de
réputation je CIS il est de je c'est la
Quadrature du Net ou pas pas du tout je
sais pas je sincement je me trp TR non
le truc des écoles de journalisme c'est
que euh je pense qu'on elles ont le
souci de former des gens pour qu'il
trouvent un boulot tout de suite et pour
qu'il trouvent un boulot tout de suite
en fait elles leur apprennent à se
former se cultiver travailler le
contradictoire et tout ça mais surtout
être apte à travailler tout de suite
pour là où ils ont le plus de chance
d'être embauché et je comprends la
logique embauche c'est juste ça peut
être très problématique aussi parce
queos closus chez les journalistes non
il y en a pas mais par contre ça peut en
fait du coup quand tu sors d'école et
que tu as 22 ans 23 ans moi j'ai pas
fait d'école le journalisme
euh tu tu veux trouver un travail et
donc tu vas là où il y a le plus
d'offres et mais tu y vas souvent en
disant ok je commence par faire des
infos gênées je traite un peu de tout ou
du Desk je pose ma voix sur des sujets
euh pour la télévision moi je connais
surtout cette partielà mais mais mon
rêve dans 20 ans c'est de faire du
document du Grand documentaire et après
4 ans 5 ans à BFM ou ailleurs tu vas
peut-être passer au service société de
France 2 et tu vas faire des sujets qui
vont être chouettees à faire et qui va
te faire traverser et puis en fait il y
a un parcours un peu académique comme ça
qui est le le fait du marché ou du
système ou et après un certain temps tu
as envie de faire de passer plus de
temps en disant je veux pas faire des
sujets en de jours j'ai envie de passer
plus de temps pas tout le monde n comme
ça il y a après des journalistes qui
spécialisent sur des sujets le conflit
et qui qui veulent ne traiter que de
conflit de guerre et tout ça il y a moi
ce que je trouve de dommage en écour que
en tout cas ce que j'essaie de dire
c'est surtout d'écouter ses propres
centres d'intérêt ses passions
c'estàdire que si on veut trouver un job
il faut rendre une il faut avoir une
histoire intéressante à raconter pour
s'intéresser à une histoire il faut
avoir un intérêt personnel et il faut et
c'est un métier qui est tellement dur
qui est tellement précaire ù qui est où
il y a tellement de gens qui quittent ce
métierl après 8 ans d'ailleurs 8 ans 8
ou 9 ans après l'école de journalisme
que tu as intérêt à être honnêtement
passionné par ce métier là moi quand
j'ai commencé c'est quoi ma question
c'était les écoles de journalisme ça je
sais plus tuécoute quand je te parle euh
ouais mais j'ai fait j'essaie de
construire des réponses tu essayes de
construire ta réponse la question c'est
tu t'en rappellees de ta question bien
sûr c'était quoi il y a pas trop de
militants politiques dans les salles de
rédaction ah c'est vrai ok tu vois ouais
ouais non je trouve pas euh
je trouve pas qu'il y a trop de
militants politiques ce soit droite
gauche ou centre he non il y a des ouais
il y a des journaux il y a une presse
d'opinion il y a des journaux d'opinion
de presse écrite il y a une télévision
d'opinion qu'on a vu
là version sous extasie non mais avec le
avec avec Pascal pro oou là il y a eu un
déchaînement comment comment tu analyses
ça d'ailleurs ah je
je comment j'analyse quoi pourquoi ça
marche pouri les je vais je vais
t'expliquer euh ma perception et tu vas
me dire si on a une perception qui peut
être
commune à force de [__] en boîte les
mecs de droite depuis un certain nombre
de décennies vous avez créé des monstres
qui vous les journalistes ah ouais ils
peuvent être différents les un ou non
mais d'accord je suis désolé de les
mettre tous dans le même sac avec un
parpin dedans ok infiniment
désolé à force d'avoir mis en boîte de
vous être foutu de leur gueule de les
avoir regardé de travers
vous avez créé des
monstres vous comprenez c'est qu'à
chaque fois que la déontologie
journalistique n'était pas présente et
que le journaliste a mis son petit grain
de sel de militant politique en face ça
crée des monstres
ouais al je dis pas que Pascal Pro est
un
monstre mais à force de voir prendre le
contrôle de la parole
médiatique de l'imposer ça crée des
monstres
ok non
mais ce que je suis absolument convaincu
que soit à droite ou à gauche bien sûr
non mais moi je c'est ce que je disais
au départ c'est que pourquoi il y a une
défiance si grande contre les
journalistes c'est parce qu'il y a une
confusion entre l'info et l'opinion
c'est exactement le sujet dont on parle
là c'est dès l'instant où on va délivrer
de l'opinion alors qu'on est payé pour
faire de l'info on confuse et on trompe
et et le problème le le problème de ça
c'est que bien sûr que c'est à nous
journalistes de réfléchir sur notre
façon de faire et notre éthique notre
responsabilité et on doit tous s'inclure
dedans et réfléchir à ça mais le le
l'algorithme qui va pousser beaucoup
plus l'opinion que l'information nuancée
il existe aussi qui bah je sais pas sur
twitterel d'ge bah non mais je sais pas
sur sur sur Twitter ou sur Facebook les
Twitter leaksentend
parler lesquel Twitter lex les derniers
là non non tu devis être intéressé c'est
pas mal ok ce que je je voulais juste
dire c'est que Twitter files ok je vais
regarder vraiment mais ce que je voulais
juste dire c'est que la il y a la il y a
il y a la responsabilité des
journalistes est-ce qu'on produit de
l'info de l'opinion est-ce que voilà il
y a la responsabilité de de est-ce que
attention est-ce qu'on n'invite que des
gens qui ont la même opinion du même
bord et ensuite on se retrouve avec tous
ces G qui n'ont jamais été invités qui
vont tous se retrouver chez Pascal pro
et c'est aussi un élément de réponse de
Pascal pro pour dire ouais mais attendez
moi ils sont tous ILT ils viennent tous
chez moi puisqu'ils ne sont pas ailleurs
non non il dit il dit autre chose il dit
nous on invite tout le monde mais tous
ceux qui sont à gauche ils veulent pas
venir
ouais après quand ils viennent c'est pas
ouais le le problème le problème c'est
que quand si tu vas chez Pascal pro tu
n'es pas interviewé tu es attaqué je
rappelle de l'interview de Christophe
Deloire pai à son â prer ou ah oui mais
c'était dégueulasse c'était horrible en
fait et c'était bah c'était horrible
parce que il y avait cinq personnes en
fait parce d'ailleurs ouais puis à son
âme mais c'était terrible et je pense
qu'il faut c'estàdire que les monstres
ont commencé à vouloir mordre c'est ça B
c'est parce que on lui pose une question
mais toutes les 2 secondes on le recoupé
donc c'est en fait c'est de la pseudo
interview c'est du pseudo journalisme
c'est du pseudo plateau il se passe pas
ça là sur d'autres services public bah
pas de cette façonlà non par non c'est
plus malin mais mais non mais là je je
veux pas je veux parler de cas précis je
parle ouais non mais je parle juste de
ça qui est un exemple de euh de de de de
là où on en est et euh et de la et de
cette gravité en tout cas en revenant
sur cette interview là de Christophe il
était c'est le le le système mis en
place autour de lui pour s'acharner dès
qu'il commençait à émettre un élément de
réponse en fait c'est fait ce système-
là est un spectacle qui est fait pour
qui va nourrir un algorithme qui va très
bien se partager se disséminer sur les
réseaux sociaux inter parce que ça va
faire des un truc très tweetable très
partageable de 20 secondes de 30
secondes où les gens vont se régaler
d'un spectacle de violence et vont le
repartager en toute irresponsabilité
c'est là où je voulais en venir c'est
que les jouralistent que tu peux me
formuler ça différemment avec le point
de vue opposé est-ce que tu peux te
mettre dans la peau des gens qui a en
face c'està-dire penser contre toi même
ouais non mais bien sûr mais mais moi je
pense à
à je peux je peux être en face aussi moi
en fait je suis pas je suis de je suis
citoyen aussi et tout ce que je dis
juste c'est que je suis père de famille
aussi je vois comment mes enfants
s'informe qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on apprend à l'école publique sur
l'accès à l'information pourquoi
pourquoi tu es obligé de préciser public
non parce que c'est l'État qui paye
parce que c'est le programme de de
l'État l'État c'est bah l'État c'est moi
c'est nous c'est toi c'est c'est notre
élection c'est notre vote c'est notre
butin de vote de quoi c'est attends JEE
je finis sur ce sujet là de l'accès de
l'éducation à l'info et après la
deuxième question ce sera est-ce qu'on
est encore en démocratie
ok sur l'éducation à l'info pour moi ça
c'est un sujet clé c'estd que pour
revenir à ça on peut s'interroger nous
machin et tout l'information l'opinion
les chaînes le la concentration les
milliardaires les fact checkers les fa
checkers nous on travaille avec beaucoup
de factc checkers ça je peux en lesqu
lesquels financés comment par où
sélection comment par nous par nous est
recommandé par des organisations de
presse le New Yorker qui nous fait qui
nous a renvoyé des fact avec qui on
travaille et tout le le moi je trouve
que le pour éviter que demain toi ou moi
on repartage un truc sans se poser la
question de notre responsabilité en
repartageant euh si on n'
pas une éducation à l'accès à l'info de
à quoi ça sert l'information dans une
démocratie on apprend les maths on
apprend l'histoire géo on apprend il y a
des cours de voilà de de de de de de
techno de tout pourquoi on n pas plus de
cours sur l'accès à l'information
qu'est-ce tuas pas trouvé la réponse bah
non j'aiai pas la réponse il faudrait
que tu commences à te poser la question
c'estoi la réponse al mais je te pose la
question tu t' as l'air de connaître la
réponse non non je suis pas là pour te
donner des réponses ah ouis ben non en
tout cas que est-ce que est-ce que les
politiques ont besoin d'une population
éduquée formée
affutée je te pose une question oui bah
oui bien sûr ils ont besoin ils ont
besoin que il
aotte le papier au tour du
chocolat bien bien
bien j'aime beaucoup cette non mais
attends juste sérieusement sur
l'éducationis très sérieux mais si tu
commences à me faire t éléments de
langage de jeis pas langage j'essaie de
répond communiquant je suis très très
sérieux non mais moi je dis pas non mais
moi je suis pas d'accord avec toi pour
dire les les le chef de l'État et les
ministres les gouvernements veulent un
peuple idiot et non éduqué au médiia je
pense pas ça je je le pense pas
et non tu devis regarder américain
humoriste ouais ok c'est en fait la
réponse que la question que je t'ai posé
c'est issue de son sketch ok d'accord
c'est dans ma tout dou liste après le
truc mais voilà je disais juste je pense
que le on a une responsabilité tous
là-dessus et que l'éducation a l'accès à
l'info de comment moi mon fils ou ma
fille ont accès info à quel moment ils
repartageent ou pas sur TikTok sur insta
c'est un truc très important comment se
fabrique la viralité il y a l'algorithme
qui te propose quelque chose qui va
trier pour toi qui va te connaître mieux
que toi tu te connais qui va te rendre
addicte qui va te rendre addicte c'est
fait pour ça c'est pensé pour ça donc
nous il faut qu'on s'adapte en face la
cyberurveillance il faut qu'on s'adapte
en face la désinformation faut qu'on
s'adapte en face et ces 10 dernières
années s'est passé des trucs très fort
et on est inadapté on est totalement
inadapté et et l'accès à l'info toi ou
moi nous tous je te
rassure peut-être plus adapté c'est en
fait tu t'adaptes à quoi tu veux
survivre à quoi moi ce que s'adapter tu
connais la la réaction darwinienne de la
contraintey T adapté à quoi tu vas
adapter la démocratie ou tu ne comprends
pas la mutation et les menaces autour de
la démoc sincèrement ce que pour
[Musique]
le une façon pour moi de m'adapter à
l'écosystème
me dangereux dans lequel évolu les
journalistes je parle des journalistes
assassinés je parle les journalistes qui
F le travail quo ouais enfin il suffit
pas d'être être assassiné donne pas un
label de il faut pas être assassiné pour
tu connais la la phrase du
l'intellectuel d'extrême droite là com
monsieur pas sil est
intellectuel un journaliste c'est soit
un chômeur soit une [__] c'est ça ou
soit mort ouis soit mort on le rajoute
par que tu es làou non je connais pas tu
l'as déjà entendu ouais j'ai oui j'ai
entendu un J soit un chôur soit une pu
j'ai entendu ce genre de truc là c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai non c'est pas vrai V
pourqu dis pas plus souvent pourquoi les
journalistes le disent pas plus souvent
ben moi je le dis c'est pas c'est
absolument pas vrai et puis je dirige
une organisation qui poursuit les
enquêtes de reporters assassiné mais
c'est important de de le redire bah
ouais c'est tu veux des perches encore
non non non mais bien sûr je le je le je
le je le dis je le dis pour ça et et ma
façon de m'adapter c'était la question
de l'adaptabilité de l'être humain face
à une menace moi c'est de penser au
collaboratif ok il tuent pourquoi il ont
tue les journalistes on les tue pour une
information qui gêne donc parce que ça
gêne leur business parce que ça gêne je
sais pas une révélation qui va gêner
mais si on assure on peut pas assurer la
la survie physique du journaliste une
augmentation de mort journalistiquement
parlant là cette année à Gaza oui il y a
une augmentation de il y a il y a
beaucoup de journalistes qui ont été
tués à Gaza cette année 136 160 combien
ouais il y a plus de plus de 120 j'ai
pas le chiffre exact mais c'est
catastrophe on a fait un projet qui
s'appelle le projet Gaza qu'on a publié
en juin et qui raconte le ciblage par la
israélienne de journalistes à à Gaza et
juste je finis sur le journalisme
collaboratif comme une solution
d'adaptabilité pour pas perdre trop le
fil c'est et c'est pas une phrase de
communicant mais c'est juste pour aller
au bout d'un truc qui est important
c'est que c'est que tu es venu pour
pousser des cadis ou quoi non je venu
pour expliquer que le journalis
collaboratif c'est une solution pour
nous adapter à un problème et et que que
quand sicilio Pineda ou quand daphneé
voilà ils sont assassinés bah c'est
important de travailler ensemble et de
poursuivre leur travail parce que ça va
envoyer un petit signal à ceux qu's ont
tué que en fait ça servait à rien et que
en fait ce qu'il voulait cacher se
retrouve à la une de plein de jour donc
la date vibité par le groupe le travail
collaboratif ce qui est loin d'être
facile les journalistes sont formés pour
devenir des loups solitaires les
journalistes sont formés pour travailler
tout seul tout seul toi et ton ego les
journ sont formé he quand tu as pas
d'ego bah quand tu as pas d'ego quoi
quand tu as pas d'ego tu travailles tout
seul ouais ben non toi non c'est c'est
un milieu où tu as énormément d'ego
comme d'autres d'ego d'orgueil a
beaucoup quand même je journalistes
c'est c'est des fois ils ont du mal à
passer les portes hein je suis
absolument d'accord et c'est pas la
seule profession euh non plus politique
aussi ouais la politique il y a
des hein politique c'est une profession
euh politique c'est ouais c'est une oui
c'est en tout cas c'est un mandat c'est
une Activ mais attends non je voulais
juste parler du du du modèle du loup
solitaire c'est les journalist sont
formés dans les écoles de journalisme
pour travailler seul il y a le cours que
j'ai fait à l'école de sciences pour
jour çaavait jamais été fait avant c'est
que on on doit penser différemment dès
l'école de journalisme dire en fait si
je parle d'un problème environnemental
qui se passe en fait qui commence au
Guatemala en fait il concerne aussi la
France le truc parce que le nickel est
exporté et que la boîte qui me vend avec
un slogan très vert et on vous doit des
comptes en fait cette boî là elle peut
être impliqué dans le meurtre d'un
journaliste ou dans l'emprisonnement de
journaliste ou participe à à ces
offensifs contre l'accès à l'information
donc c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire avec
avec cette approche là qui va à
l'encontre de ce qui est enseigné dans
les écoles de journalisme on t'enseigne
à à travailler tout seul avec ta source
tout seul avec ton RA chef à monter tout
seul sur scène pour recevoir le prix et
et et voilà donc ce qui et c'est pas un
exercice
facile notre travail à forbidon avec
toute équipe c'est de convaincre de
nouveaux partenaires de travailler
ensemble travailler ensemble c'est dire
tu partages tes informations demain tu
vas sur le terrain ben tu tu donnes à
d'autres et parfois c'est tes
concurrents au quotidien mais tu
partages l'axe deination tu partages
éventuellement l'identité de ta source à
un autre journaliste tu partages tu te
répartis le travail c'est un exercice
très difficile comme dans beaucoup de
métiers cours de métier où tu dis non
attends j'ai j'ai 40 ans je vais pas
aller partager mon temps avec mais en
fait pour forbidon on le fait parce
qu'il y a un intérêt majeur il y a une
personne qui a été tuée il y a un tueur
en liberté il y a un sujet qui est
important le sujet qui est important et
concerne un pays et pas que et euh et ça
envoie un signal la souveraineté du pays
les intérêts économiques du pays donc du
chômage donc de la précarité
l'approvissement des services publics et
la liste peut être longue euh j'ai une
question
euh alors déjà Gaza euh il y a pas si
longtemps que ça on s'est retrouvé à
table avec un reporter de Guer très très
connu qui a travaillé sur beaucoup
beaucoup de conflits et on lui pose la
question comment ce qui est pas mon cas
ouais non mais il a travaillé et
travailler ok on on s'entend bien et et
on lui pose la question on dit bon alors
Gaza est-ce que tu peux me dire ta
réaction face à la boucherie
journalistique qui alors le mec il
déplace son rumentaire et puis il finit
sa phrase par
bon on sait pas trop si c'est des
journalistes c'est des gazoui tu
comprends et là je dis que je comprends
pas tu tu vois le le la perception je
vois il y a une journaliste red chef
adjointe du Red chef du point et j'ai
oublié j'ai oublié son nom mais qui a
tweeté qui a effé son tweet en disant il
y a pas de journaliste à Gaza cette
pensée là elle elle existe on l'a
entendu dans le projet Gaza c'est très
grave c'est très très grave je pour
replacer un peu dans le contexte de ce
qui se passe à Gaza sur les
journalistes le on est don
donc je sais plus combien en est à des
dizaines de m000es morts plus à de 60000
morts civiles on pense en c'est quoi tes
chiffres c'est quoi tes sources mais
souvent les les sources sont les sources
du Hamas qui dirige politiquement
administrativement le la bande de Gaza
mais le les j'ai vu des études qui
montraient que souvent les sources du
Hamas correspondaient aux sources des
des rares ONG qui étaient présentes et
tout ça dans les estimations de chiffres
donc il y a pas trop de doute à avoir en
tout cas euh
il y a non mais il y a des Nations Unies
qui sont qui sont qui sont sur place et
qui ont des bureaux et qui peuvent prend
des bombes aussi ou bien sûr il y a des
pertes il y a aussi des civils d'ONG qui
qui sont morts ces derniers mois euh et
donc les journalistes sont parmi les les
survivants ont leur
famille pareil visé tentent de faire
leur travail peuvent travailler pour
aljazira pour alaxa TV qui est affilié
au Hamas pour une chaîne qui est pas qui
est financée par le Hamas pour de
manière indépendante pour Reuters enfin
il y a tout type de de de profil nous on
a on a dans notre enquête on a on a
prouvé que euh par exemple il y avait 18
journalistes on essaie de comprendre un
peu le schéma global est-ce que l'armée
israélienne ciblait les journalistes
parfois on avait pas la preuve pas la
réponse et parfois on avait des
indications et je je peux en donner
quelques exemples où clairement l'armée
israélienne avait l'info de sur qui il
tirait et tout il y a 18 journalistes
qui ont été une perte collatérale ouais
mais c'est que si les journalistes
étaient avec des gains un peu chelous
bon bah voilà quoi oui mais tu sais ce
qui se passe sur la question des pertes
collatérales c'est que maintenant la
question des pertes collatérales on s'en
remet à l'intelligence artificielle il y
a un programme qui s'appelle la vender
qui a été révélé par un jour qui
s'appelle yval Abraham qui a travaillé
avec nous sur le projet Gaza qui
travaille pour une une une publication
qui est fabuleuse qui s'appelle plus 972
et qui réunit journalistes Israéliens et
Palestiniens ensemble ils ont révélé
avec l'aide aussi du gardien qui a
participé à cette enquête-là
l'utilisation d'un programme qui
s'appelle laavendeur et qui en fait s'en
remet entre autres à l'intelligence
artificielle pour suggérer des cibles
euh target division target room et les
cibles sont suggérées en fonction d'un
d'un d'un certain niveau d'indicateur le
la la la le la connexion IMEI la
connexion du téléphone portable avec ces
trois personnes qui sont affiliées au
Hamas la conversation que cette mêmeci
peut avoir vont ensuite désigner ce
téléphone là cette personne-là comme une
cible à abattre et ensuite ils vont se
poser la question des pertes
collatérales que tu évoqué et le les
révélations de yval Abraham et du
gardian avec des sur la base de source
israélienne disait on a des on a des
quotas de perte acceptable
euh et il révise ça avec des avocats
pour dire pour tel haut gradé du Hamas
on peut se permettre de perdre tant de
pertes de de dommage civil un ha gradé
égal on peut aller jusqu'à 20 pertes
un un une personne moins moins élevée
dans un rang de de décision du de la
branche militaire du Hamas c'est c'est
tant de personnes donc il y a des ratios
suggéré par une plateforme la vendeur
qui suggérait ça donc nous dans notre
enquête qui était si qui était qui
portait sur les journalistes puisque que
c'est notre mondat la forbidon stories
on a révélé entre que 18 journalistes
avaient été soit tués soit blessés visés
par des drones c'est intéressant l'usage
du drone parce que le drone à la base
est fait pour éviter les pertes
collatérales le drone est fait pour que
l'opérateur est sur un écran HD sa cible
et souvent le drone est téléguidé par le
téléphone portable sur lequel qui qui
vise donc peu importe où tu vas et la
rue que tu prends le drone te suit et
euh et il est arrivé dans 18 cas que ces
journalistes là soient visés donc il
savaient coup sûr qu'ils étaient
journalistes beaucoup d'entre eux
portaient des gilets presse il y a 11
journalistes qui ont été tués à l'ORS
qu'il portaient 14 journalistes qui ont
été tués alors qu'il portaiit un gilet
marqué presse tu sais qui tu tu qui tu
tues donc voilà et moi je vais te dire
je me fais l'avocat du
diable un jour un parbal avec un scratch
press je t'achète ça sur Internet ouais
bien sûr non mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est ce que alors c'est le oui c'est le
discours de de Tal de dire de de l'armée
israélienne de dire on a vu et ce qui
est vrai je crois des attaques commises
par des membres du Hamas déguisés en ça
reste
mineur c'est juste mais ça reste ou non
mais ça reste non mais après il y a un
truc important c'est
que mais pour aller chercher d'autres
gars bien sûr mais c'est juste que le
c'est un conflit assez particulier c'est
un conflit qui est totalement fermé
c'estd que on peut pas y aller euh c'est
un conflit où il y a un blackout en
terme de communication qui est organisé
des réseau coupés application coupée
parfois électricité régulièrement coupée
c'est un pays où il y a il y a les
journalistes en fait ne sont pas
protégés ils doivent l'être les
Conventions de Genève le précise c'est
pas qu'ils sont des civils plus
importants c'est que il crois encore au
Père Noël non j'y crois pas je dis juste
je je pense juste que il y a les seules
de droit qui existe elles vont elles
vont peut-être être utilisé un jour par
des magistrats tu par ah oui peut-être
un jour bah il y a des actions mené en
tout cas devant la Cour pénale
internationale pour pour pour que les
belligérants rendent des comptes CRIM de
guerre le président de la Cour pénale
internationale il a pas dit qu'il était
en train de se faire menacer par des
chefs d'État sil commençait à aller sur
netou si mais surtout ou il a été le il
y a une autre enquête aussi je du
gardian et je pense aussi 972 qui
révélit l'effort de lobbying énorme pour
autour du président de la cénale
international pour de de la part
d'Israël pour pour l'influencer mais sur
la ça rappelle pas quelque chose
d'ailleurs ça comment il s'appelait le
monsieur qui était censé enquêter sur
les armes de destruction massive du
Hamas de en Irak ouais c'est Blitz Blitz
blit je su parti en Irak en 2000 en 2000
en 2004 et j'ai fait s'en fous non non
mais non non mais sur ce sujetl tu as
mangé des carpes euh non j'ai des carpes
de quoi tuas pas mangé de car non je
suis passé un mois là-bas tu étais où en
irac tu étais resté dans ton hôtel non
non non j'étais j'étais avec l'armée
américaintais dans quel hôtel
non j'étais pas j'étais pas j'éta tuarmé
américaine déjà ça commence attendsiss
tu faisais un tour opérateur tu faisais
quoi non j'ai fait un truc s'appelait j
en irac parole interdite et qui
racontait et qui donnait la parole à des
militaires américains sur place qui
raconta comment le avait menti et qu'ils
étaient venus trouver des armes de
destruction massiv WMD et qu'ils en
avaient pas trouvé et le documentaire et
se passé pas seulement à Baghdad en Irak
mais j'étais allé retrouver des soldats
américains à l'Hôpital Américain à
Arlington l'hôpital mé où étaient
soignés les les les premiers amputés de
la guerre américaine et c'était des
images qu'on voyait pas et c'était et
toute l'ARM américaine était faisait un
blackout total sur les images des amputé
il fallait pas voir les morts et blessés
américain et donc le documentaire qui
faisait 70 minutes c'était un
documentaire sur des patrouilles que je
suivais au quotidien et le regard qu'ils
avaient sur sur bouche qui les avait
envoyé chercha des armes de destruction
massives dans un pays où ils étaient pas
voulus du tout quoi donc c'était c'était
donc j'étais pas en hôtel j'étais
directement B avec ces gars-là j'avais
il faut que tu parle français ici
j'étais pas
j'étais intégré dans la troupe en tant
que journaliste et et et et je l'ai
filmé au quotidien avec mon pote
Alexandre Johnny on était parti là-bas
j'étais parti là-bas c'était pas une
commande j'ai fait ça pas mal de fois
parce que comme j'étais jeune personne
me faisait confiance mais moi je voulais
vraiment le faire et du coup avec mon
pote j'avais écrit un mail à l'armée
américaine qui depuis qui depuis sa base
à DOA ou je sais plus où pour le
demander si c'était ok pour que je reste
un peu de temps pour documenter tu as
écrit à l'armée
américaine forcecr nous on écrit
département d'État américain bien sûr au
service de presse de la force qui
s'occupait de des accréditations presse
des journalistes à Bagdad donc là ils
t'ont fait de P je leur envoyer un mail
pour dire j'aimerais bien raconter le
quotidien la vie au quotidien et donc
ils sont dit un journalist j'éta j'étais
personne c'était en en en 2004 donc je
suis né en 67 parfait et et ils m'ont
dit oui et j'ai dit ça à mes potes journ
qui étaient plus âgés quoi ils tont dit
oui j'avais pas fait grand-chose à
l'époque pour ça c'était peut-être pour
ça et j'avais aucun financement et
j'avais aucune chaîne j'avais proposé du
poo non non non non franchement il
m'ération il m'ont dit tu viens quand tu
veux j'ai d je viens avec mon pote Alex
qui avait une caméra et un HF et on
était on on était parti tous les deux
comme ça sur notre argent de poche au
Cachmir en Palestine plusieurs fois et
là cette
fois-ci en Irak on était allé une un an
plus tôt on avait tenté de passer la
frontière en Irak et là j'avais fait un
sujet en freelance aussi sur des
journalistes qui étaient à la frontière
turque qui raconaient la guerre en Irak
200 km plus loin mais qui ne la voyaient
pas j' fait ce su pour arrê sur image à
qui j'avais vendu ce sujet Combien le je
sais pas de jours ou TR jours de pige ça
m'avait coûté beaucoup plus parce que
j'is passé du temps là-bas Serman il est
pauvre sujet pendant lequel j'avais
rencontré Paul Morera pour la première
fois là-bas ouais mais il a mangé des
carpes moi je sais pas je moi je je
mangeais au restaurant de La de la des
des troupes am
et mais voilà en tout cas ce ce ce
comprends ma boutade du fait que tu
étais plus S et qu' t'ont fait rentrer
très facilement et c'est pour ça que tes
copains qui avait de la bouteille ils
ont fait oh il y avait aucun risque il
avit avait aucun risque comme ils ont
pas vu que tu étais possédé par le démon
ouais mais c'est un hack journalistique
tu t'en es même pas rendu compte mais
souvent on m'a dit ça on m'a dit en tout
cas je j'ai j'ai pas j'ai trompé
personne en fait mais j'ai la chance du
débutant mais chance débutant et puis
surtout change du débutant et puis j'y
croyais j'avais trop envie de le faire
c'était une aventure aussi d'amitié avec
un pote c'était sympa à faire et puis
c'était une aventure de vie parce que on
voyait on était pas beaucoup plus âgé
que les jeunes militaire américains qui
étaient là et qui était de la National
Guard et qui était en étude d'architecte
tout ça et qui débarquait là quoi et qui
était très intéressant et qui nous
racontait voilà le leur regard leur
déception et ce doc il est encore
trouvable sur daily motion tout ça et
tout euh la liberté de parole qu'ils ont
face à notre caméra rappelle le titre j
en irakq parole interdite mais c'était
en 2004 donc c'est il y a 20 ans donc
c'est a très longtemps mais euh ensuite
voilà oui l'hôpital waltery d'hospital
c'était là où j'étais allé pour aller
rencontrer des journalistes aussi que
normalement on pouvait pas filmer et
c'était un militant d'une association
qui m'avait dit cache ta caméra euh je
vais te montrer les vrais blessés de la
guerre américaine et on a passé le
portique du waltery D' Hospital et il
m'avait amené dans un coin où j'ai pu
interviewerver des amputés et aussi des
supérieur inférieur face euh des jambes
et j'avais pu intervouver un ancien
desffces spéciales mais qui avait 22 ans
et qui était qui souffrait de PSD
syndrome post-traumatique ouais syndrome
post-traumatique et qui racontait en
tremblant des jambes l'opération sur
laquelle qu'il avait traumatisé disait
et ça c'était vrai c'est pour ça que le
documentaire s'appelait parole interdite
parce que c'était très rare franchement
à l'époque euh d'entendre d'entendre ça
tu as fini ouais je peux te poser une
question et qu'est-ce que tu penses des
journalistes qui se font emmener en tour
opérateur par l'armée X ou l'armée Z
pour aller se balader que c'est
vachement bien et que tout va bien et
qu'ils vont rien il voi rien un peu un
peu Robocop tu vois tu vois le Robocop
où ils sont sur un théâre d'opération je
peux te parler de ouais alors je peux
parler de je connais parce que j'ai FA
et là je rebondis sur le conflit à Gaza
le conflit en Ukraine le conflit de tout
ça parce que autant on les journalistes
occidentaux se font plaisir à mettre en
boîte les journalistes russes autant les
journalistes russes se font un grand
plaisir de mettre les journalistes
occidentaux en
boîte toi tu es au milieu tu les
regardes tu essayes
d'analyser la question que je te pose
c'est ils ont une responsabilité dans
l'augmentation des conflits les
journalistes ou pas tu vois ce que ce
qu'on appelle journaliste pour toi on
mettra une catégorie à part pour toi
Morera plinel et d'autres mais est-ce
que tu penses que c'est publier
reportage facile tu appppelles ton
ministère de la Défense tu dis écoute
j'aimerais bien couvrir ça l'autre il te
dit t'inquiète Mimile tu vas monter dans
le VAB on va te montrer tout le beau
matos qu'on a envoyé nos stress et toi
qui a une expérience où les images
cachées de de la perception cachée de et
ainsi de suite c'est quand
même problématique
ouais non mais les voyages tour
opérateurit c'est toujours problématique
et c'est un immense problème à traiter
euh sur les théâtres de guerre et il y a
de des journalistes qui ont perdu leur
vie aussi en sortant de ces Gil jaquier
en Syrie par exemple et il y a pas mal
de journalistes qui essayent de sortir
de ces sentiers imposés où on te dit
attendez pour votre sécurité vous allez
surtout pas sortir dans cette rue et
vous venez avec nous dans le véhicule
blindé et vous faites surtout pas autre
chose moi j'ai fait juste pour raconter
un truc sur les voyages de presse moi
j'ai fait un documentaire qui s'appelle
mon président est en voyage d'affaires
et et et j'ai suivi j'ai demandé à
François Holland s'il était ok pour que
je le suive sur deux voyages euh
présidentiels des voyages officiels en
Azerbaïdjan et au Kazakhstan et il a dit
OK et je l'ai suis c'est toi qui a fait
la photo où il est habillé avec euh Chka
c'est pas moi qui est fait c'est le pH
c'est le c'est le photographe du
président kazak de l'époque nazerbayev
qui l'a fait mais j'étais là euh la
chapka est magnifique mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a l'air con j'étais là le
lendemain matin quand la le service de
presse de François Hollande sa
directrice de presse aux relations
internationales découvre sur Twitter que
son boss le président François Hollande
a une chapka et moi j'étais dans ce
voyage là j'aienquêtaé en fait sur la
corruption à quand même à haut niveau
qui impliquait EADS et et je j'ai posé
des questions à nazerbaayev au général
Puga qui était euh qui était mes les
cibles de mon enquête en tout cas les
personnages que je voulais rencontrer
mais c'était intéressant voyage de
presse parce que quand on a fait quand
on fait un voyage de presse avec le chef
de l'État on est briefé en amont donc on
est reçu dans une annexe de l'élysé et
euh on nous dit bon ben voilà le chef de
l'État va rendre visite va aller dans ce
pays-là et voilà le programme il y aura
et on mange à telle heure voilà non non
mais mais attends mais tous les journés
sont pas des moutons non plus attends
apportons un peu de nuance et qui c'est
qui dit que je pensais que c'était tous
des moutons tu crois que tu es là
pourquoi de quoi moi je je je je dis ce
que je sais et ce que j'ai vu surtout le
tu as dit ce que tu sais et tu sais ce
que tu dis NON je je non mais j'ai j'ai
assisté à cette conférence de brief des
journalistes sur le Kazakhstan il y
avait sincèrement un dintérêts de la
plupart des journalistes parce que c'est
un pays que personne n'arrive à situer
sur une carte euh on parle de
journaliste là on parle pas des mecs
ouais mais parce que c'est bah parce
qu'il y a des pays plus peut-être plus
banquéb que d'autres et que c'était le
Kazakstan c'était un peu paumé donc il y
avait pas un super intérêt et puis la
visite se passe François Hollande sert
la main de du président kazak va dîner
les journalistes bah rentrre à leur
hôtel moi aussi moi j'avais mon plan en
tête de euh de je veux absolument poser
une question à François Hollande et à
nazerbayev et c'est pas facile de poser
une question et je vais expliquer
comment pose les questions parce qu'il y
a quand même un un ordre à tout ça et le
lendemain matin
j'arrive j'arrive et je vois que je vois
que je suis à côté de la directrice de
la communication qui dit mince il a une
chapc sur la tête qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé et le truc est déjà repartagé le
truc est parti et elle comprend que en
fait c'est le photographe de du palace
du président kazak qui a fait qui a fait
la photo et qui aa balancé sur le compte
Twitter de du site officiel de la
Présidence du
Kazakhstan et là ça devient shapka gate
et là pourquoi shapk gate tous les
journalistes se disent mais on a un
sujet il y a des blague c'est une blague
et non non et il y a eu plein de sujets
on peut vérifier il y a eu plein de
sujate parce qu' on lui a offert une
chapka non c'était il y avait des des
gnalistes qui disaient ok de quoi est
faite la chapka c'est de l'agnau c'est
du mouton c'est quoi est-ce que on offre
à chaque fois une chapka à chaque truc
pourquoi le présid on apportter une
chapka et tout est-ce que tradition du
pays et la tradition du pays et façon
tous les pays ont font ça il est parti
avec un tapis ou pas non et est-ce que
les journalistes repartaient avec des
tapis
alors des des élus politiques oui ça
j'ai fait une enquête dessus sur les sur
les tapis d's j'ai fait expertiser le
tapis d'un
élu et tout juste pour finir il av pas
de My non par contre il va aller cher
combien il va aller faut vérifier je
crois 6 ou 7000 € plus que le tarif de
150 € qui est le seuil au-delà duquel en
tant qu'élu tu dois déclarer ça mon
président est en voyage àffire donc
c'était un doc que je faisais pour cach
investigation j'avais demandé à Hollande
de suivre en azerbaïjan et au Kazakhstan
au Kazakhstan il s'était passé ça le
protocole de questionnement le protocole
de questionnement hyper intéressant
merci de ramener là-dessus c'est le en
fait moi je connaissais pas et je vois
des
journalistes qui couvre d'ailleurs
l'actu géopolitique qui sont bons et
tout vraiment mais mais je comprends et
j'arrive dans l'avion et je dis il faut
absolument que je pose une question tu
es qui je suis caché investigation ah
ah attends il y a des règles pour poser
les questions on a droit à deux
questions par délégation de journalistes
en fait à chaque fois qu'il y a une mais
c'est comme ça depuis toujours quand le
chef de l'État français reçoit l'Élysée
et je l'ai j'en ai fait l'expérience en
poser une question à Erdogan qui m'a
valu beaucoup beaucoup de menaces
ensuite et un énorme buzz
mais le il y a une il y a un processus
qui processe en protocole qui fait que
chaque délégation de journaliste les
journalistes français et les
journalistes casazak ont droit à deux
questions chacun sauf qu'il y en a 20 et
20 comment on fait et donc il y a une
petite tradition qui de donner aussi une
question à lafp l'agence de France Press
qui va pouvoir poser une question tu
sais comment s'est appelé en Afrique AFP
non Agence France propagande ouais ouais
je peux reven pour revenir sur
l'histoire de forbid stories nous il y a
aussi des journ de FP qui sont gravement
menacés enlevés tout ça mais et qui font
vraiment leur boulot juste sur le
questionnement moi mon sujet c'était je
veux poser une question au président
nazerbayev et au président français
parce qu'il y a des affaires de
corruption entre les deux pays et je
veux avoir des réaction là-dessus et et
donc on me dit ou il aura que deux
questions donc il faut pas de souci le r
il faut que tu arrives à convaincre un
peu tout le monde et en fait dans
l'avion j'ai commencé à passer de siège
en siège et être faire mon relou et à
voir les journalistes et à leur dire toi
tu je l'ai fait sur l'Azerbaïdjan aussi
et le Kazakhstan et le dit toi tu fais
quoi comme sujet ils m'ont dit je fais
peut-être un petit sujet pour expliquer
le pays le contexte tout ça et je leur
dis et moi à chaque fois j'essayie
d'expliqu de vendre mon truc moi ça fait
6 mois que je bosse dessus c'est des
affaires de corruption d'élu ou
d'entreprise qui concernent la France et
tout et et là pour la Kazakhstan on m'a
dit
euh il m'a dit on verra ça demain matin
au petit DJ avec tout le monde donc je
suis arrivé j'ai entendu l'histoire du
chapka gate machin et tout et puis là
les journalistes m'ont dit bon cach
investigation c'est bon tu poses la
question parce Queen fait il y avait un
intérêt c'est que la question allait
faire du bruit parce que je posais des
questions sur la corruption mais donc il
faut
s'organiser c'est clair que les les
chefs d'État peuvent pas prendre non
plus 40 questions pendant 3 Hees et
faire surtout François Hollande s'il est
capable de répondre à 3IS c'est déjà
bien en tout cas il peut pas faire une
conférence servview pendant 3 He Macron
c'est pareil pourous leè non plus hein
ouais Emmanuel Macron j'ai fait
l'expérience aussi sur un autre une
autre visite officielle ça cette fois-ci
dererdowan le président turque qui
venait en en France et qui venait rendre
visite donc à Emmanuel Macron et là moi
je faisais un sujet à ce momentl sur la
coalition internationale en Irak et sur
la responsabilité
entre autres de plein de monde mais turc
d'avoir laissé passer plein de gens qui
on ensuite combattu dans les rangs de
daesh d'alqaïda et j'avais posé une
question erdan là c'est pareil j'avais
dû aussi convaincre les autres de dire
j'ai une question assez précise et j'ai
fait ce sujet pour spécial à l'époque
pour dire est-ce que je peux poser une
question sur sur le sujet de la guerre
en Syrie et au Président on m'a pas
demandé plus l'isé m'a pas demandé plus
je m'a dit qui pose la question c'est
Laurent pour envoyer spécial c'est sur
quoi j'ai dit la Syrie le conflit pas
demander plus et après j'ai posé la
question et ça et Erdogan est du
foudrage parce que José posé cette
question il m' dit tu es qui toi tu
penses comme mes opposants d'où tu tiens
ces preuves là et donc je lui expliqué
que il y avait un journaliste John
dundar qui était le redchef de jumouriet
qui avait été condamné pour ça et donc
je poursuivais le travail de de John
dunda dans ce dans ce sujet tout ça pour
dire que les voyages officiels les
voyages de presse il faut savoir sortir
évidemment des sentiers qui sont bien
balisé pour nous parfois on peut nous
dire qu'effectivement c'est au nom de
notre sécurité qui sont si baliser que
ça et qu'il faut les suivre euh et le le
le le jeu c'est de d'en sortir aussi
pour pouvoir tenir son angle et essayer
de d'enquêter d'avancer sur son sur son
enquête
question tu as voyagé un peu en Afrique
non pas trop non en Afrique non mais
ailleurs un peu m comment ça se fait que
les journalistes sont ciblés alors
certes par les à gauche et à droite et
dans les mouvement contestataire ou
terroriste ou machin c'est les
journalistes c'est des espions ah oui
est-ce que le corps
journalistique fait du ménlage pour
certains certains
services est-ce que des photos
reporteurs qui ont travaillé pour un
grand canard français on travaillé pour
les services et est-ce que ça ça nuie
énormément à votre capacité être sur le
terrain moi je je sais que tu as déjà
posé cette question là aussi à d'autres
gens journaliste sincèrement je pense
que parce que j'ai regardé une émission
je crois où tu posais la question à edwi
plinel
ou Fabrice harfille tu as regardé
combien de vidéos euh trois ou
qu
pourquoi c'est j'ai besoin de
justifie c'était non mais c'était très
intéressant le le sincèrement le sujet
des journalistes qui travaillent pour
les services de
renseignement en France je sais pas trop
je l'ai pas vu tu connais pas assez de
journaliste c'est ça non mais
sincèrement euh non je l'ai pas vu en
tout cas je l'ai pas vu ont le droit de
confesser ça que 30 ans après benah en
tout cas je pense que si si ça existe
sincèrement moi j'en ai pas entendu
parler je l'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu de
journalistes qui me disaient qui dont je
me disais tiens en fait euh le soir il
va filer ses infos à la DGSE j'ai pas vu
ça pourquoi le
soirre ouais un journaliste qui se fait
kidnapper ça coûte combien à l'état de
le faire libérer ça je sais pas je sais
pas du tout parce que on vraiment
travaille pour le qu'est-ce que tu
penses
de l'ffaire télégram avec Pavel qui
arrive sur le territoire français qui se
fait passer les bracelets euh je sais
pas trop quoi en pensaer parce
que bah commence par un début non sur la
conversation privée est-ce que ça change
quelque chose sur le travail
journalistique est-ce que ça change
quelque chose sur le compte d'Emmanuel
Macron sur telgram est-ce que ça change
quelque chose Pavel durof pour info son
numéro de téléphone était dans la liste
des numéros ciblés par Pegasus et un
truc intéressant et c'était à priori les
Émirats qui étaient derrière le ciblage
de Pavel du ROF pourant il il est Laé
émirati entre autres un truc intéressant
qui a révélé le Wall Street Journal mais
selon leurs sources je sais pas comment
ils savent ça mais ils ont révélé ça la
semaine dernière c'est que donc nous les
infos sur le ciblage de Pavel du ROF
c'était des infos d' de ciblage
potentiel donc on sait pas s était
infecté parce qu'on a pas pu analiser
son téléphone de
2018 mais en 2017 selon W Street Journal
et on sait pas quand en 2017 le papier
ne le précise pas c'est une année
d'élection Pavel du ROF aurait été ciblé
dans une opération conjointe
d'espionnage entre la France et les
émirat Arabe Unis aurait été ciblé sur
son téléphone euh donc je ça c'est
sincèrement j'en sais pas plus je trouve
juste que ça c'est un truc à creuser qui
est hyper intéressant de pourquoi la
France qui lui donne d'ailleurs la
nationalité et tout aait participer
conjointement avec les Émirats à une
opération qui aurait impliqué peut-être
un outil comme Pegasus je je je sais pas
mais c'est des questions parce que c'est
sorti aussi la semaine dernière j'en
sais pas plus sur l'application telgram
ça je peux dire un mot oui elle est elle
est elle est pas recommandée par
beaucoup d'experts en sécurité qui
pensent que l'pp le le le le il y a pas
un tunnel de chiffrement de bout en bout
entre une la personne qui appelle
l'autre personne
et que les informations donc du coup
sont stockées sur des serveurs et que
dès l'in dès l'instant où c'est stocké
ailleurs que sur l'appareil celui qui a
le serveur a l'information et donc
l'information peut aller à celui qui la
demande un état qui fait une réquisition
ou un service de renseignement qui
demande un coup de main donc télégram
c'est dingue d'imaginer d'ailleurs que
de savoir d'ailleurs que beaucoup de
membres du gouvernement utilisent
beaucoup télégram c'est dingue aussi que
nos données de santé nos données
concernant l'entretien des réacteurs
nucléaires français soient pas stocké en
France
ouais question une autre question
l'affaire à Sange ouais l'affaire
Snowdon plus la faire à songe parce que
à songe collatéral damage tu vois ce que
c'est la vidéo ouais ouais de Dirac
Dirac ou euh euh WikiLeaks la plateforme
WikiLeaks euh informer publi ou périr
ouais euh euh 14
ans dans des dans une
ccérationenfer des journalistes ciblés
qui étaient en contact des avocats
ciblés qui étaient en contact avec
Assange ouais toi ton avis c'est ils
font passer un message que les lanceurs
d'alertes les journalistes si vous
moutez trop absolument tu vas ressortir
avec 35 kg et puis tu vas c'est 14 ans
en tout cas ouais ce que je pense c'est
que pourquoi les États-Unis sur le cas
de snowen d'assang je tienneent autant
affiche autant de fermeté faut pas que
ça fasse de petit c'est qu'il faut pas
que ça ça ça ouais il faut pas que ça
fasse de petit ça c'est c'est certain
que c'est c'est ils sont pris en exemple
ils ont révélé des secrets militaires
ils ont révélé des documents
confidentiels ça ne se fait pas leur
source eux-mêmes seront poursuivis pour
toujours
et Snowden pour le coup j'ai pu discuter
avec lui au début de forbidon stories
dans son c'est oui c'est un héros
moderne de de de l'information de
l'accès à l'information une figure euh
Assange à à une face sombre une face
qu'on connait mais c'est aussi il a vécu
l'enfer absolu qu'on ne devrait pas
vivre quand on participe à à une à à
ouais à à éclairer l'intérêt général
l'opinion publique grâce à au câbl
WikiLeaks euh au câbles révélés au au
communications diplomatiques on a appris
plein de choses sur des crimes de guerre
gravissime après l'approche d'Assange
c'était de dire tout document doit être
rendu publicque comme ça la je sais pas
si tu connais didos secrets qui est une
plateforme qui a une qui une sorte de
Carrefour des leaks euh et des hackurs
eux ont une autre approche qui dire euh
toute donnée doit pas être forcément
rendu publ par contre on doit travailler
sur les données et il faut que les
journalistes viennent à nous on donne ça
à des journalistes pour qu'ils fassent
leur travail dedans et ne mettent pas en
danger d'autres personnes dessus et qui
a un travail d'investigation là-dessus
est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
aimerais aborder avec nous parce que ça
fait quand même 2h41 qu'on est 2h41 ok
je pense que ta fê ce soir tu peux te
brosser ah ouais je suis attendu c'est
dommage
euh est-ce que les fa ét question
Internet est-ce que les failles de
Pegasus ont été colmatées par les
fabricants de
téléphone est-ce qu'il laisse certaines
failles pour les gouvernements ça tu en
sais rien des des des bac d'or des
portes ouais dérobé alors sur les
failles de Pegasus
euh il y a ce qu'on sait il y a la
réalité en gros et les les géants qui
vendent des téléphones qui sont dans le
téléphone Google Apple communique pas
énormément sur la dimension sécurité le
projet Pegasus je pense sincèrement les
a poussé à faire un peu plus que ce
qu'il faisaent au départ ils font des
notifications aux victimes ils ont
travaillent ave c non non il y a
beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de victimes
qui ont été là pour ceux qui te voient
pas tu joues du violon tu joues du
violent devant moi mais il y a beaucoup
classe class est-ce que tu as vu ce un
violent
élégantch un orchestre philharmonique
mais euh non il y grâce à grâce à ces
notifications on a découvert l'usage de
Pegasus au Salvador par exemple ou ou
ailleurs et tout donc ça participe un
peu je pense qu'effectivement les
budgets alloués à la sécurité dans
l'industrie téléphone reste toujours
sans doute 20 fois inférieur à ceux de
la communication dans le domaine
téléphone au moment où on publia le
projet Pegasus il y avait des photos des
pubs Apple partout dans dans le métro
parisien c'était iPhone c'est votre pour
votre sécurité et nous on travaillé sur
le truc donc les failles Pegasus est
toujours vendu toujours utilisé
l'entreprise Aness Group qui
commercialise Pegasus a perdu des
clients à cause de la réputation euh en
a gagné d'autres ces clientsl on sont
allés chercher d'autres entreprises des
des salariés de NSO sont partis en parti
sont partis euh ils sont pas repartis en
Italie à ce momentl mais non sont partis
sont restés en Israël pour rejoindre
d'autres boîtes qui ont revendu à
d'autres États euh voir même plus cher
des licences d'expl de de logiciel
espion donc non juste sur le pour finir
sur une note dramatique et pessimiste le
lot léiciel espion Pegasus je disais ça
au départ on il y a pas beaucoup il y a
pas grandchose pour pour s'en protéger
euh déjà techniquement tu ne sais pas
que tu es infecté zéro clic euh trouver
une preuve que tu es infecté encore
faut-il que tu es le doute que tu d'être
infecté et que tu es sous la main des
gens qui sont fabuleux comme comme les
gens d'amnesie scurit ctizen Lab ou
d'autresest et il y en a AB Brest aussi
qui vont qui vont faire de l'analyse et
il y a des cliniques qui se développe
comme ça connais ce de Brest non mais je
connais très bien Amnesty et citizon Lab
et heureusement et juste un truc sur sur
Amn ils ont fait un truc qui était
fabuleux au moment du projet Pegasus
c'est que au jour de la publication
c'était en juillet 2021 on avait donc
les articles de prê eux avaient les
traces d'infection
et ils ont dit on va révéler notre
méthode on va rendre publique notre
méthode et il y a eu un débat interne
Amnesty et on avait fait faire un P
review on avait faire une contreexertise
par Citizen Lab aussi pour vérifier que
les résultats scientifiques étaient euh
confirmés par d'autres scientifiques de
manière indépendante l'expérience était
reproductible voilà et euh Amnesty
seccurit Lab a décidé de rendre publique
sa méthodologie comment ils avent troué
ça il y a eu un débat pour dire mais
attends si tu rends publ euh euh ta
méthodologie NSO en face va s'en serv
pour faire disparaître les traces et ils
ont choisi de rendre public ça parce
qu'en rendant public ils ont rendu
public le code pour mettre en place ta
propre clinique pour trouver tes traces
et dans le monde entier tout le monde a
utilisé le code qui était mis à
disposition gratuitement publiquement
par Claudio garnieri et Donka au Caro
qui sont deux gars qui ont moins de 30
ans et lany au lendemain de nos
révélations s'est retrouvé à développer
à utiliser le code de ces deux par il
est fort ah ouais mais ils l'ont fait
ils l'ont fait réellement ils ont pris
le code ils développé pour aller trouver
et convoquer tous les ministres pour
qu'ils viennent avec leur portable pour
faire les analyses donc les failles ont
été
patché sans doute sur le sur le moment
il y en a d'autres qui existent tout le
temps l'industrie de la
cybersurveillance elle est très
résiliente pourquoi parce qu'il y a un
marché je faut juste parler d'argent
c'est ça coûte pas ça coûte pas 1000 €
d'infecter une personne c'est des
millions d'euros donc les for fait varie
en fonction du client ça se vend
beaucoup plus cher à l'Arabie Saoudite
que à l'Azerbaïdjan par exemple mais et
aussi un truc important pour parler de
l'Europe
c'est juste Pegasus c'est pas que des
États autoritaires qui l'ont utilisé des
États membres de l'Union européenne
l'ont utilisé aussi l'Allemagne a
utilisé
Pegasus et ça et ça c'est très
intéressant
verb pourquoi c'est intéressant pour uno
d'avoir un pays membre de l'Union
européenne qui utilise ça c'est parce
que ça fait monter le le prix ensuite
plus tard c'est parce que attendez les
Allemands l'achètent on a Gérard qui est
membre de notre bord ancien ambassadeur
de France laisse tranquille on est une
entreprise absolument respectable et et
voilà et donc ce marché européen là tous
les pays européens n'ont pas du tout
acheté la France ne l'a pas acheté nous
on a Babar
ouais mais tu connais babaris Babar
c'est une bonne BD je te conseille ok
mais Don voilà donc sur sur Pegasus et
sur la cyber surveillance il y a un
énorme besoin de de mobilisation à tous
les niveaux dans notre société pour
prendre conscience du problème que c'est
pas juste une histoire de metadata c'est
une histoire de nos viis c'est pas juste
une histoire de de de
ben j'ai rien à cacher donc je m'en
fiche du du sujet jusque là c'était un
peu ça la réaction de l'opinion publique
nothing to nothing to hide euh mais
c'est non c'est une question de
démocratie en fait
euh le documentaire nothing to hide de
sur attends c'est le documentaire sur
Snowden ou c'est non je sais plus sur la
surveillance je sais plus pass c'est
très bien renseignez-vous sur Babar
c'est
rigolo tu as fini ouais moi j'ai fini je
suis très long question Internet est-ce
que tu as un ami
imaginaire non est-ce que tu crois en
Dieu non d'accord tu crois quelque chose
au journalisme ok je crois au forbid
stories dire je crois ENISE lu
j'ai un hôtel de la dévotion avec sa
photo chez moi quand je rentre j'allume
une bougie Brini je crois Brusini tu as
Hervé Brusini je crois en HERV Brusini
ah ouais ah non mais HERV Hervé Brusini
c'est un peu comme j
PEI il règle les problèmes ah ok on
l'embrasse il est en épade là non ah non
non non il est brillant il est frais et
il est italien et il est italien ouais
c'est clair qu'il est frais non mais je
dis ça parce que je sais qu'il va nous
regarder et quand il va entend quand il
va il va bon passons euh est-ce que tu
utilises chat GPT ou une intelligence
artificielle dans ton métier euh non si
parfois pour faire traduire des
interviews h euh certaines interview pas
sensible beaucoup d'experts ouais ça
peut être trint on utilise trint qui une
solution de d' est-ce que tu crains
l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificiel
dans le métier de journaliste euh oui
pourquoi
ah bah déjà ça va ça va être maintenant
plus besoin de déléer une dépêchep non
non alors attends je peux dire deux
trucs un l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans la désinformation ça
c'est un vrai problème et on l'a vu avec
le projet story killers de je vais citer
un exemple d'utilisation d'intelligence
artificielle qui est sidérant
extrêmement triste et qui pour le coup
protège les journalistes là et ça se
passe en ce moment au Venezuela où des
journalistes sont totalement menacés et
du coup on crée des avatars avec
l'intelligence artificielle pour
présenter les news et c'est intéressant
parce que c'est un groupe de différentes
organisations de presse qui s'unissent
qui font des enquêtes et ensuite il se
dit qui va l'antenne maintenant c'est
trop risqué d'aller à l'antenne on va se
faire buter et donc là ils ont un ils
créent un avatar qui qui ressemble à une
pub de champoint ouais qui Ress
champoint donc parfois le il garde le
sourire quand il annonce des des
informations donc c'est pas encore très
réglé je te rassure sur franis ils font
la même chose mais c'est une initiative
en tout cas qui est important de
connectas qui a un réseau de de
journalistes en Amérique latine et qui
utilise pour pour le coup l'intelligence
artificielle pour protéger les les
journalistes
là alors je regarde les question
internet euh il a Harry Clinton a même
utilisé une messagerie perso mais on
s'en fout non c'est important mais les
c'est sur c'est sur le fait que ancienne
secrétaire d'État américaine se baladait
avec des mails sur son mail perso et que
bon passons est-ce que tu as un sujet
que tu souhaites aborder avec nous qu'on
a pas abordé ou pour la fête non là on a
bien fait le tour je pense on fait le
tour ouais je crois bon 2h50 pas mal
est-ce que tu as
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
mais avant est-ce que tu pourrais nous
donner trois l trois livres à lire pour
notre communauté euh
oui très rapidement sans raconter les
livres et tout ça mais
et il y a je t'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure un livre que j'ai lu très
récemment qui s'appelle Act leak and
Revelations d'un gars qui s'appelle Mik
li m I c a h plus loin li l e e et et
qui est le chef sécurité de Z intercept
un site d'information américain qui a
développé onion onion chare qui est un
système de partage de d'information et
en fait il bon c'est vraiment pour un
public de journalistes intéressé par
l'accès et l'accès au au l et le
traitement des lic comment on cherche
comment on les indexe et comment on
cherche dedans et il y a pas mal d'infos
sur cet écosystème là et donc ça c'est
un livre intéressant un autre livre moi
qui m'a
je me rappelle plus des chapitres par je
l'ai lu il y a 20 il y a 25 ans
s'appelait blacklist de
borjenson une auteur qui a retrouvé qui
a interviewé qui fait le récit de 12 ou
13 journalistes américains qui racontent
leur histoire de censure travailler pour
CBS pour CNN et raconte le jour où une
histoire é
censurée un troisième mais j'ai un
conflit d'intérêt là-dessus c'est
informer les pasansali qu'on a coécrit à
16 journaliste français vendu combien
c'est vendu je sais plus tu prends je
sais plus ça doit être vendu 15 € je
sais je sais plus si toujours V je pense
que si oui je pense qu'il se commande en
ligne mais c'était c'était C pardon je
pasendu ce soir il va être commandé sur
notre
communauté mais en tout cas il y a Paul
MOA Fabrice SFI Benoît
Colomba d'autres journalistes on raconte
tous un bout d'histoire de
pression de pr pression de censure dans
le journalisme français
et et voilà est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur les
serveurs de YouTube réfléchissez avant
de partager réfléchissez avant de
partager ouais voilà en rapport à tout
ce qu'on s'est dit avant Laur merci
merci à toi merci à vous
[Musique]